okay what up guys welcome to the just
pearly things youtube channel today is
episode 6 of the pregame
before i start do not forget to
subscribe to the channel and bring that
notification bell you guys already know
if you have watched three or more of my
videos and you do not subscribe okay we
got beef
beef people okay
um so today's sponsor is cooking with
chris he offers a completely custom made
meal plan that allows you to eat
delicious foods while being your
healthiest self so as you guys know
as you guys know i've been doing this
meal plan for like two three
three weeks now and i'm down
seven pounds so i recommend it all meal
plans that you buy with the link in the
description go towards new equipment so
if you're trying to live a healthy
lifestyle
if you're trying to you know get in the
gym i recommend it
okay so today i have three guests on the
channel and it was funny because i just
walked up to you and asked you like
randomly on campus and asked you to come
on my show i was like okay
um so we're gonna go around and do name
age and relationship status
okay so i'm going to stop yeah okay so
hi i'm tiana um
i'm 20 years old and i'm a psychology
student
obviously the question oh yeah i'm
single
hi my name is rhys i am 22 years old i
am single um owen i'm 18 so i'm like a
baby here and i'm
single by her so like
did you say single but at home
um also where are you guys from put that
too
what do you mean
like where were you born where are you
from i was born in the uk in the uk yeah
i was born in the uk hormone hospital uk
yeah so this is the first show that i've
done where it's mostly um british people
like most of the time it's been
americans yeah
okay
um so today's topic is
do women actually want equality or do we
only want equality when it benefits us
so
this first the first question that i'm
going to ask
is would you be okay with going 50 50
with a guy
um
i don't know it depends like on the
situation like i feel like if i'm giving
50 50 then like if it's 50 50 and it's
completely equal then i'm completely
fine with it okay but like it's really
rare for that to happen like i guess
what do you mean like
let's say you're pregnant he can't carry
the baby for fifty percent of you yeah
yeah like it will never be equal equal
so that's why like hypothetically if it
was to work then yes so when you're
dating do you typically like want a guy
that makes a certain amount of money or
does that matter to you
i guess it doesn't matter how much they
earn i guess it's like
like what do they bring like
but like what do i bring at the same
time i don't know
so first date would you be cool with um
a guy
not paying like you pay for the date or
like splitting the bill and you can
still go on a second date
i think so yeah okay you'll be fine with
that yeah do you guys what are your
views on that do you pay for first dates
i've never been on a date but like a
proper day um
but yeah i usually well i'm gays like if
i'm with a guy
oh yeah
yeah it'd probably be like oh i'd know
like i'll pay no i'll pay now i pay them
one of us to be like okay all right
and then pay yeah
so if it happens then yes
yeah okay okay i'm usually like oh okay
you insisted like i'm very easy to
okay
i don't even know where to start
honestly
um it depends on the
to be honest it doesn't depend on the
situation for me it's just
who wanted to go out on the date firstly
he won this guy on the day but second
year
um
for me
if it's a first date we're not going to
anywhere fancy we're going to we're
probably going to go to the park for a
walk and talk because
i don't know you like i don't i don't
know you i haven't
had any type of conversation or or
anything with you so
the first first thing we're doing is
walking in the park if we're hungry
we'll go and eat
who pays for that
me personally i don't care like it's
like it's
i'm not on a date for you
with you for you to
pay i'm on a date with you to get to
know you so it's about the intention of
the date for me it's not about
whether you're paying or she's paying
nothing
but that doesn't answer your question
though does it
[Music]
that doesn't answer the question yeah so
i don't think i can give you an answer i
just for me it's just
more so
yeah so i was like what do you mean 50
50 like inject like a date or like in
general like i meant in general so like
see you're you're a little bit young
because you're 20 right so i it seems
like it matters more to girls like the
older they get
but a lot of girls like want a guy that
pays like 80 70 of the bills
as opposed to like splitting the bills
50 50.
or um if they get if they want to get
married and like have kids and stuff
like
they want to take a couple years off and
be with a guy that can do that
so i'm just curious if that's something
you care about or not
i guess like if he earns more that like
he would pay more for bills so it would
be fair like let's say he earns
like 70 more than you then he could pay
like 70 more rent or like make it like
two thirds rent he would pay and then
other the rest that i would pay but
depends on the situation like if i was
to earn like double what he earns that i
wouldn't be like yeah 50 50 because then
like
yeah
but you'd be okay with dating a guy that
like makes less than you yeah okay okay
what um
the next question
what
what is the difference between a guy who
spoils his woman and a guy who's whipped
it's difficult
oh boy
like how embarrassing it is
yeah
it depends on the guys like
are they the same guy like out like just
for
example reasons
is it the same guy so let's say same guy
let's
theoretically same guy
same amount of money in his account
uh and that's that's basically it so
it's the same guy is that is that
always
i didn't really get that far on the
question yeah i guess we could do two
two twin brothers
that make make a hundred thousand a year
so what's the difference between him
being whipped and yeah
and one that's i both are whipped
they're both wet they're both whipped
because you
you're spending how many how much money
on your
female but haven't you got that you
used to be getting that money in the
first place you must be doing something
so
where are you spending your time
like your time has to be
somewhere else your time can't be with
you your girlfriend all the time or
whoever it is all the time you gotta be
you've got to be other places
so in my opinion if you're doing that
you are whipped you're both whips wait
if you're doing what if you're spending
any money on a girl no no not any money
you said a lot right
um no i said what is the difference
between a guy who spoils his woman and a
guy who's weapons i didn't say i didn't
say how much money yeah even even
suppose so it depends on your definition
of spoilers
like what's what you're what that's what
i'm asking you about
like what's spoiled to you
[Music]
that's a good question yeah i have to go
back to you on that on the uh question i
was thinking more like i feel like if
it's like in terms of whipped i think of
like the girl is just using him for that
and then she's not really that
interested but again it's same thing of
like
it's um
[Music]
i mean in terms of like male or female
like there's um a lot of like
women that do that like with a lot of
money for young guys there's a lot of
men that do that for other guys but like
in terms of like
if they're whipped i would think of that
as like they're just using them for the
money and it's kind of sad and it's like
oh they're kind of whipped because of
that but yeah that's what i was thinking
too kind of i feel like it depends how
interested like how
interested the girl is
like because a lot of guys don't mind
spoiling a girl as long as she's like
like
very like submissive to him i guess oh
submissive yeah i think it's like kind
of like really a role thing like like
being spoiled is like maybe the girl
like he wants to take a girl in that
kind of sense and then being whipped is
like the girl's kind of like in the
position of power and she's like yeah
you have to spoil me like you don't have
a choice like yeah yeah
yeah those way around it's more like
oh i'll let him buy me these things yeah
so it's kind of like maybe a power thing
do you not like the word submissive
no no it wasn't because i didn't like
the word yes like
does your female have to be submissive
for you to spoil her like because she
said most guys in my head i was thinking
wait that's not me
that's what i'm thinking it just it
seems like guys that make a certain
amount of money like really
like the girl to kind of just like do
what they say because
they make all this money like they're
usually pretty like competent they don't
really want to come home and like argue
with the girl i think so you think
they're people that make like men that
like like a lot of money will like want
to have a submissive girlfriend
hypothetically i think what you guys
gotta ask is
how did they make that money and how
long did they have that money for yeah
that's true that's true like uh someone
who gets money overnight is very
different than someone who's built
wealth that's very like been wealthy
yeah yeah yeah yeah okay fair enough
exactly so like
that yeah that's the question just how
long has he had that money for because
if he's a guy that
has worked for his money and then he
decides okay i'm going to spend my money
on her
because
i don't know she deserves it whatever
whatever his reasoning is then
to me
whatever his reasoning is i believe that
his reasons would be the right reasons
because he knows how long it took
for him to get what he got yeah and now
he
is whatever he's built he's sharing it
with his he's a significant other
so
in that sense
i'd say
that
where am i going with this
well we were talking about submission
yeah yeah
yeah in that sense i'd say
i don't think it's
her being so him wanting her to be
submissive i just say it's literally
just love
and that's it
yeah cause there's actually like there's
a kink like a specific kink of making
someone spend your money i've heard of
that like rich guys they'll make people
like waste their money and it'll be like
a kind of like sexual thing for them you
imagine like being so rich that like you
have that
you never unlocked it
i'm so rich that allowed to spend my
money
yeah imagine
i'm a magic listen here you go here's
100 whatever no i've heard that's common
in like like nba players and like but
but you also hear about entertainers
that get rich quick going broke quick
too
i think like money habits like they
spend money and maybe like
extravagant look like luxury things that
like a normal person would spend money
on like if you normally had like a lot
of money like the average person that
makes that is wealthy in the uk probably
wouldn't have money to go but like go on
a yacht buy a yacht and do those kind of
things but like nba players are kind of
like a different level yeah yeah
yeah that's true
um next question
do you think that um
are you would you consider yourself a
feminist
yes okay do you think do you want
equality
yes
um so when it comes to equality do you
think that
women should make up like 50 of the
military
no why if you want equality
i don't
like i'm i think i'm anti-military so i
don't really believe in like people
going to war like fighting and stuff
okay i also don't believe that like
women should have to force me like
should be forced to fight i do feel like
that men are physically able to do
things that like women would have to
train a lot longer to do so i don't
think it's fair to make a woman do those
kind of roles
and yeah like i feel like not all
elements of life have to be 50 50 for
equality to be there okay what do you so
what does equality mean to you like what
do you what do you think we're still
like fighting for in 2022 like equity
like equality
could work but if like equity is like
making it work for like what's fair like
if someone's like better send soon roles
then that's okay okay i appreciate
femininity and not like okay a woman has
to be a man to be accepted for it to be
feminist for it to be 50 50. like a
woman can be as feminine as she wants as
powerful she wants not have to be
something she's not for it to be equal
like 50 50. so you don't advocate for
like 50 like all the jobs should be 50
50. like when they talk about like for
example like met like ceos and stuff
that doesn't have to be like 50 women 50
men
i feel like that's a bit different like
in the working world because like it's a
job and like most jobs nowadays well a
lot of jobs that um a lot of men do i do
think that women can do as well like i
don't think there's like like the
military that's a very physical job i
think it's quite different but like a
lot of jobs aren't in that world and i
feel like they all should be accessible
and those should be allowed to have this
50 50 balance yeah well do you
is there anything like stopping us today
to like become a ceo
what do you mean like so like like me
and you were girls like if we wanted to
become a ceo we could right yeah
so
um i'm just curious like what do you
think would stop us yeah i feel like um
a lot of people see men being ceo so
it's like that feeling that like oh i
didn't expect you to be the ceo like
okay believability like a lot of
businesses and like a lot of marketing
is like oh like people like believe in
like you're confident it comes across
that way and people kind of believe in
what you're saying a lot of people don't
believe in confident women like oh this
is a scam i don't believe what they're
talking about i don't trust what they're
saying because just because they're a
woman they don't believe that they're
capable i think that could stop someone
becoming a scene wait who who doesn't
believe we're capable i feel like a lot
of people have that like stereotype or
like have this opinion that maybe they
were just not believable
as being like ceos do you so do you have
the same like belief like bricklayers
should be 50 women and 50 men and
plumbers and electricians or is it only
ceos
it depends on the job i mean i think
bricklaying i don't know how physical
the job is i have really no clue like
what they do apart from laying bricks
like i don't know what kind of demands
and like what kind of skills you would
need but if a woman wanted to be
bricklayer and she thinks she can then
why not but i do feel like some roles
maybe it's better to have more women in
those roles or maybe to have more men in
those rooms yeah no i agree with you
like i think it should be but to me i
don't think there's anything like
stopping us from doing any role today
you don't think so no nothing i think if
i i think if i wanted to be a ceo i
could be a ceo i think you could but
yeah it'd be a lot more difficult in
comparison for when a man tries to
become a ceo but you realize there's
like specific grants for women that
aren't given to men that's true but i
don't think you're actually like it's
the next one you're actually on an event
that was an all women's business thing
actually wasn't it that's true um i'm
going to take an event called um yeah
it's not just the boys but like
i don't think that that one event is the
same makeup for like
i don't yeah i don't think that makes up
for like the majority of technology and
it world being like male dominated how
do you know the difference between women
just choosing stuff that they're
interested in
like for example i don't know a lot of
girls that want to be plumbers and i
used to work for a plumbing tech company
so we like sold stuff to plumbers and we
would go to schools and it would be like
one two plum like female plumbers in the
room and plumbers make a lot of money
right it's just not like a glorified job
but how do you know the difference
between women not um wanting to do those
jobs
and
and like discrimination because at the
other end of the spectrum like my dad
he's the ceo of a company and my dad
worked 80 hours a week my whole life to
get to that position right like since i
was i barely saw him my whole life i
don't know many girls that would want to
do that mm-hmm like
so so
yeah
yeah
oh i wouldn't like do you want to i
don't want to do that
but like how do you know that because
you're talking about like systemic like
like discrimination that's against us
but how do you know the difference
between women like choosing what they
want to do and just
and discrimination
i guess it's a difficult thing to figure
out i mean yeah it's hard to divide the
two it's hard to see the difference
between someone actually being really
motivated and like hard working and
really trying hard yeah do you think if
someone really tries hard and really
works maybe
hours a week they could get somewhere
yeah but i'm not going to say it's going
to be easy yeah and maybe a guy would
have it a lot easier than a woman if
like if you're if i was talking 80 hours
and your father was like 80 hours i
think maybe there'll be a difference
well i don't um actually i think it's
easier for women um i don't yeah because
we're offered like my um dad put his
company under my mom's name so we could
get like specific grants and like tax
exemptions like for women so they give
us like an easier path to it
i think i guess so i guess there's some
opportunities there of being a woman i
do think my sister's an engineer oh yeah
i think that makes a huge difference
when she's applying she's like yeah yeah
she's a girl there's like
what what like a hundred male applicants
and one woman like i think she's like
one of three and a whole like aerospace
engineering course that makes a huge
difference maybe she gets more attention
more support yeah there's more like
opportunities there but i do think in
the mail world yeah a place is male
dominated i don't want to be the first
woman in the room and being that i don't
think it's an easy job i feel like you
have to be like 120 better than
everybody else
i feel like the opposite i feel like
girls are given special treatment and
they're given stuff that they don't
deserve
because there's special grants for women
that aren't offered to men do you have
special treatment though or do you think
that's like oh can i interject
go ahead go ahead
yeah we've been talking about here's my
here's my question to you
okay um
do you think
it is
easier
for women
to get a job than men
it depends on the job so if i want to be
a babysitter i feel like okay as a woman
i'd have like a great advantage a lot of
people want feminine people to look
after their children
but if it was a different kind of role
then maybe not
okay okay so
let's say i wanted to drive a tractor
or if i wanted to lay bricks and there
was a woman that was a man who do you
think would have the
higher chances of getting that role like
no skill set just no skill set just on
the get-go like if i apply and you apply
for a brilliant job or a babysitter
who would have a higher chance of
getting
in my opinion
okay the person with the most dedication
and the most um uh
i want to say passion towards the job
okay we both have no experience and no
passion
there you go dedication because i think
that's personal bias
personally like i don't know because i
know a lot of people that do bricklaying
and plumbing and have a history of that
um but like
yeah i was gonna say like with a lot of
those grants they kind of
yeah in some cases like they're trying
to help out women because you know like
it wasn't that long ago it was but like
in terms of like
i don't know like um
like century-wise and like decade wise
there wasn't a lot of um
things for women but um
yeah a lot of it kind of
i guess kind of focuses on that and with
that focus
sometimes some good like companies and
places will kind of like want to like
show off that and kind of hire more
women or diverse like just like to be
performative not to actually okay i
really do want to see women in this
industry it's just like okay we have a
quota we have to have at least 19 uh
women on this team let's just employ 19
women even though they're not qualified
i do think that could happen i don't
think that's great but
but i think that's like i think that's
wrong i think like i don't think we
should try to make it
like 50 50. like i don't think we should
try to get women to do industry like
jobs they're not interested in like i
don't i don't know i don't know many
girls that want to be engineers i know a
couple my best friend from childhood
she's an engineer she hates it
i mean
i think that's true like yeah a lot of
people are like oh we need more women in
stem but do women want to be in stem
do you want to be i don't want to be
understand
yeah but i guess it's just like um it's
that thing about um women are more
respected when they're like
well a lot of feminist viewers like
women are respected when they are
perceived as male so they act like males
like a lot of women um dress more
masculine when they're going to a
working world
as a feminist what do you want that's my
question to you like equity i wanted to
be fairer and do you think that what did
you just say you said something about um
how you're viewed
you said something about how you're
viewed
what about it about how women are
like how women seem more masculine okay
yeah so
are you saying if you seem more
masculine you will get more respect from
a male no i i mean like
i think that was a concept of like
femininity like feminism
i think it's a bit dated now but maybe
in like the 80s and 90s like a feminist
a real girl boss was like a bit
masculine a bit like cutthroat a bit
rude a bit you know
kind of like girl bossing and that kind
of like concept is like okay
very popular and i don't really connect
with that anymore i feel like a woman
shouldn't have to become the stereotype
of a man to be respected and to be equal
i feel like a woman can stay feminine
she doesn't have to go into stem she can
do what she wants but it to be like fair
that if i did want to do that like i'd
have the opportunities to do that
yeah i just don't understand like what
like what are we fighting for today you
can go into anything you want
i think like you can like what what's
stopping like because because
we like women women like what are we
working for so so i'm saying like like i
was born in 1996. i i've always been
able to vote
i've always been able like i've always
been told since i was really young to
like do whatever you want like you can
chase after whatever career you want i'm
in i'm in a very male dominated space in
youtube i worked in a male i was the
only girl in my office in sales and i
feel like that was more of an advantage
than a disadvantage because like one men
are attracted to you they want to help
you like i think it's easier for women
and so i just don't know like what are
we fighting for
okay i mean i'm not a woman but when i
think of all my friends and like the
only family members i have are women
when i think of like um
female problems i think a lot of them
are
um just personally from friends and
stuff like a lot of um kind of this idea
of like um
feminism and how it's like warped in
certain people's like minds okay also
like
laws in terms of
like especially in like art because you
know there's some countries where it's
very different for women it's very
different yeah how they live but like in
terms of like our countries and that
um like laws against you know like in
america there's um like abortion laws
and stuff
and also like sexual assault and how
that's handed handled by the police and
my social social services and stuff
which is kind of like
iffy in certain places
so i do think like maybe in the working
world we've got like quite far but like
just general safety of women's like if i
was like walk around alone at night in
london like obviously i feel like the
experience would be different for a guy
i do not believe you guys are saying
that's well
it's sorry to cut you but i do not
believe so if you don't believe um that
we're saved and how are we supposed to
believe that like we're saved like
jeremy like well you realize men are
more likely to be victims of a violent
crime than women
statistically like they're they're more
likely to be victims of a violent crime
that could be true but like the men have
this fear like do you have fear like are
you scared to walk around at 3 am the
difference between us and you guys we
probably fear more than you guys fear
you think so
walking down the street
i don't know 1am
they can still get mugged like they can
still get stabbed
there's no crimes that will happen but i
just feel like there's a vulnerability
of being a woman especially a woman
that's like i don't know maybe not
like i can't do any self-defense things
like i know like if someone wants to
attack me like that's it that
do i have to do that no i i agree with
you like we're the weaker sex right so
we're not we're not as strong but but
the issue is again like what are we
fighting for like
safety like everyone wants to be safe
[Music]
so i just don't understand like what
legally we would be fighting for
i think legally i'm not sure like what
we would be fighting for and you said
abortion laws in the united states like
what specific abortion laws are you
talking about because
because
um
but i just i remember hearing that there
was one state that passed again this is
like you know it's totally fine yeah um
yeah like i'm not very good at pulling
off
no no you're okay
um
yeah no like there was you're talking
about texas um probably yeah probably
i'm not gonna lie but like yeah and also
like um
just the politicization of it and i
genuinely believe that like if
that situation like historically was
more like pregnancy was more of a man's
like
um
issue
then it wouldn't be as stigmatized but
obviously we can't like look at parallel
universes so like yeah that's not gonna
be a thing but like um
yeah and also like the way that sexual
assault is handled and obviously that's
kind of like in general i think but um
the way that that oh yeah sorry i'm
allowed to say that like it was
just say essay just so
yeah yeah sorry the way that yeah is
handled
um legally and um through social
services and stuff if you don't take
legal action it's just not very like
personally what i've heard and
experience like it's not a good
experience great but yeah but maybe
that's uh issue with that and the legal
issues of that than women because
yeah
yes that's what comes to mind do you do
you think that men should have a say
it's like if we're talking about
equality right and if a girl gets
pregnant she wants to have an abortion
that's still the guy's kid do you think
he should have a say in it
like do you think if he says i don't i
don't want her to get one that's my kid
in today's society i would say
no
because the situation is that the woman
is like carrying the child and the woman
um
it's quite responsive for what happens
to her body so it's gonna have a huge
like so you're just like you're
literally gonna be pushing your child
through your legs if that does if
there's a viable um pregnancy so i feel
like a lot of it is like the woman's
part but i do think that especially with
contraception as well
a lot of like women take the pill and
that's got crazy like crazy side effects
and stuff like that i don't feel like
if she got pregnant i don't feel like
it's the fault of the woman i think the
man had a lot a big decision a big part
in that i do feel like it's like i think
if if you get pregnant it's 100 the
girl's fault i don't think that i feel
like the men get very little
responsibility i'm going to tell you why
okay
because i feel like we have so many
forms of birth control that we can be on
you can tell him to wear a condom like
he takes it off
well then like don't consent to that i
mean like we're taking out take essay
off the table okay like if that if that
happens to you that is not your fault
that's that's a different different
conversation but if you're like doing it
with a normal guy
like most of them are gonna like listen
to you if if you say no right but take
sesame off the table so i feel like if
you get pregnant it's your own fault as
a girl because we have so many forms of
birth control you can track your cycle
so you know when you're ovulating you
can
um you can wear a condom
so
like that all of that is on i feel like
the girls like think about it like why
is all contraception centered around the
woman
i feel like that's another thing that i
feel like
like the woman kind of has to have like
if she wants to
get rid of that child like it's also on
the woman she has to go through that
whole thing i feel like there's not much
that the man has to the man has to go
through like the man doesn't have to
take any pills he doesn't have to get
like an implant doesn't have to take any
i think men would if they had it they
just they they just they just have it
that's actually the thing that is a male
um well i think you think drake he went
through the heart like he wouldn't take
that
like men don't want like kids running
around either
like i heard there was again i heard but
like this was like a big um thing going
around this rumor of that there was a
male contraceptive pill but it had the
same side effects of the female ones so
they still left it in production and
still
are working on it now and haven't
released it because it has the same side
effects um
of the female i think men would take it
so if this was to come out on the market
do you think like men would actually
take contraception like a pill or like
get an implant yeah like a lot of women
do i think
you know what i think it depends on a
guy i think there's a small
percentage of god like because there
aren't you know you realize like most
men aren't sexually active
you want how tall do you want a guy to
be if you're going to date him
taller than me how tall are you i'm not
sure
have you heard girls say they want a guy
over like six foot
like
that i've heard a woman be like he's
five
ten or five nine nine yeah okay okay how
what percentage of guys do you think are
over six foot
and not many in the uk just to tell you
yeah in america yeah
so it's like 15 it's 18 actually i think
percent of guys that are over six foot
so it's a small and when women swipe
right on dating apps they swipe right on
less than 20 of guys and it's 80 of
women swipe right on 20 of guys so it's
a very small percentage of men that are
sexually active so i think that
i think that those guys probably would
because they don't want kids running
around maybe not nick cannon though
yeah i think it depends on the guy okay
i'm not gonna lie it depends on the guy
because um these guys ain't sexually
active they might
they might want a kid for the simple
fact that they ain't sexually active
listen let's say there's something else
to do yeah
let's say like
i don't know they
they just want something to love yeah
they're gonna want a kid yeah they're
going to win a kid and it's like
[Music]
you can't
by the way is the woman's choice 100
1 000 because at the end of the day i
understand like i grew up around women
yeah
and i heard a bunch of conversations i
probably shouldn't have but
um
you guys go for a lot of pain like a lot
of physical pain forget the emotional
side of things i know you've got
gasoline for a lot of um
physical pain but then again and i don't
know if this is just me being a guy just
it's not our fault
it's not our fault like but like
you need to you kind of need a guy to
have that process
i need a guy to be involved it's not
even you both make that decision to
do what you do
you both made that decision it's not
just the guy that says okay cool what
we're going to do today no
yeah
i get that like both people are on board
but like i still feel like the the
female part in this situation just has
like a completely different experience
so throughout the pregnancy like oh yeah
we're pregnant but like i'm pregnant in
a situation like you're carrying the
child like you're doing the checkups
mate what are you pushing
yeah like you're just you're just there
for moral support and that's yeah isn't
moral support good like when you're
upset don't you want your friends to be
dead i feel like if you're carrying like
how much is like a pregnant baby like
how much does that weigh like he's not
gonna like hold it like
so now look
let's say it wasn't like a baby let's
leave baby out of the picture yeah let's
say you have a friend yeah and your
friend is um
i don't know your friend
stabbed his or her arm yeah okay and
they have to stay in the hospital for a
week
yeah you're gonna go and see it like
let's say this is a close close friend
are you my question to you is are you
going to go and see that friend every
day to make sure okay so like moral
support in that sense but that that's
different no no it's not it's not it
doesn't matter what sense it is i'm
saying
like at the end of the day
what
me as a man what i'm doing for you
for as a woman
should be appreciated as equally as what
you're actually going through i don't
think she'll be appreciated the same but
like you can't do any more like you you
physically can't take exactly that's
exactly fair enough
i don't appreciate it like that you're
doing a bare minimum if you go to like
those visits but but it's kind of like
why are we diminishing like men being
involved in their kids lives like i
think that's almost diminishing it
i don't think it's diminishing but i
just think because men men pet like like
like the woman can
there's like it's good for the baby if
they hear the dad around and stuff you
know
and like men still have to financially
support it more times than not
i do that that's true but like i do feel
like nothing will like it will never
match up like what the woman does in
that whole biological process in
comparison to what the man does like
physically list the things physically
what did they do they're literally
carrying the child like nine months
other than carrying the child what did
they do
they're literally like using their own
body as like a life you realize like
dogs do that like everyone like
every every animal cares
like reducing that a lot but i feel like
pregnancy is like a really like horrific
problem should i tell you why i said
what did they do because
this is what you don't no one really
talks about on the man's side
let's say it's your your it's not just a
random girl it's your your wife your
girlfriend whatever
do you know how much headache
do you know how much headache that that
man has to go through
like mentally because he might be like
okay cool yeah i'm having a child
whatever yeah but at the same time it's
like this woman is pissing can i swear
yeah
this woman is pissing me off because
like like the hormonal changes yeah i
can't deal with this so that like
exactly for the guy to stick there and
not even just so go just to be present
is like well done
i mean yes yeah it's fair like my like
um a lot of people have things where
it's like their dad doesn't turn up and
stuff like it's to be fair like
they shouldn't get a medal or a reward
but like just being there is kind of i
feel like the guy being there's like the
bare minimum like if they're both
concerned into having the child so
what's maximum
the max there's no maximum exactly the
minimum and the maximum
women for like doing what they're
supposed like you're pedestalizing women
right now because you're saying we're
carrying a child it's this great thing
like literally dog dog dogs carry like
like every animal dog i'm not gonna
pedicure
yeah like
men don't have much opportunity to do
more so give your minimum maximum is
like the same level so if you turn up
and you're there that's like the best
you can do and also like the bare
minimum that you can do so then there's
been then there's helping like this
and then there's also like helping with
the pregnancy helping when she's in bed
like yeah be there then leave then be
there but if you're there like there's
different levels to it i think do you
like
a man that can cook
i like people that can take care of
themselves
cool so i'm taking that as a yes sir
yeah cool now do you appreciate
i don't know uh breakfast in bed from a
man yes you guys had a great night you
guys
you're still in bed he woke up before
you wake up to
food fruit yeah your opinion is nice
yeah that's nice that's really good so
now the pregnancy
isn't that kind of the same thing
because it's and you're going to
appreciate that because in your waking
up thinking raw like i didn't even have
to lift a finger usually that's quote
unquote the woman's job yeah but you
this guy has gone out his way he didn't
need to get out but he got i made you
food he just like he didn't need to be
around you for those nine months where
you are shouting off his ear
he's still there though because he
understands like the bigger picture like
the big picture is is after these nine
months i have a child to raise like
she's
she can do whatever she wants she can go
chill she can do whatever but like
when the nine months come he's got
chapter race so that's why i asked do
you
appreciate the the the brexit
yeah because then you're saying that the
man being there's bare minimum but that
breakfast in bed think about he doesn't
need to do that so that's maximum
not maximum but i feel like it's
respectfully the bare minimum like if
you're just a trashy guy you can just
not be there but i'm like if you're like
a good human being
[Music]
you're still saying the same thing
like i just feel like we always are
diminishing that
like i just said it's like the past time
we've gotta catch up on
a question
do you guys ever think
what is he going through
yeah yeah
and then what's your answer like once
you think what you're going through
like
what's the answer what's asking
questions and then find out like it
depends like what's going on what you
mean like i'm single right now like what
you're going through you know true
you're talking about like a boyfriend
like what's he going through
let's just say
[Music]
um well that's what i talk about on my
channel is it advocates for men
so that that's i talk about this a lot
like i had two brothers like try to
commit suicide okay so i like men i
don't know men
go through a lot i feel like men are
always like diminished in every
situation in life like we always
downplay like how like men
and even even like in this comment like
i'm not you know trying to correlate the
two but like even in this conversation
like you're downplaying like men being a
father and how great that is like that
is a great it's a hard thing to do
um
and yeah i know i think about like men's
pro that's what i talk about all day
that's what i do for work there you go
do you think it's important to recognize
like what men go through like i do like
i do know it's like obviously like
i love women i love to advocate for
women and obviously like i'm very
defensive towards women because i'm a
woman and i've gone through like the
experience of being a woman but i do
notice that like it's not easy to be a
man like to have to be expected to earn
a lot of money to be expected to provide
it's not that's a lot of pressure to go
through as a woman you can definitely
avoid that if you want to you see for me
yeah
my thing's not as if you have a vagina
or a penis i don't like i don't care my
thing is your human being
at the end of the day let's start there
yeah
usually when guys think about females to
talk about
um
like typically like they talk about um
emotions being emotional like that's
usually the thing
cool now when females talk about guys
what like
what do you guys actually talk about
because
for me it's like what can you guys
actually say about us because we don't
like anything we do
is just wrong like in and like and when
i say anything we do is just wrong in
terms of like if
as you said
going to the um pregnancy helping and
you said that's bare minimum for us it's
like bro do you know how much [ __ ] i
have to do yeah i am putting that [ __ ]
aside coming to you attending to you
and then you're going to tell me this is
the bare minimum in our heads we're like
[ __ ] this i'm not coming back
i'm going to go go work and go do what i
got to do for me
because i'm not being appreciated here
and i in my opinion i think with most
men wow
but most men our thing is
we don't get appreciated at all
like i don't think that's true not at
all not at all we do get appreciated but
like
we
have like okay you see how women get
like a um
uh a a leeway if you know that i feel
like it's not always leeway it's kind of
like pity sometimes like a lot of like
like when women are like my tyres broken
in my car like oh it's pretty it's just
like oh a woman you look nice yeah pity
like oh like she can't do it herself
i think i don't think men don't get that
men don't get that
most men that's not what we think that's
not what you think we're just thinking
oh
she needs help she's a woman like let me
help because for us what's what's kind
of ingrained in us is just you need to
be a gentleman like that's kind of
ingrained we don't i kind of even i have
that
but i kind of have that with both like i
don't think of gender when i do that
there you go that's interesting i don't
you're just a human being someone needs
help i'm like yeah of course like you're
gonna want to help them and stuff like
that there you go so like my thing is
like
with the appreciation now
going back to the the the pregnancy like
don't you think that we're going through
a lot more than
meets that
i do say that a pregnancy is very
centered around the woman the whole
experience is kind of like her
experience i do think there's obviously
things going on and concerns for the guy
but i do feel like the experience with a
woman is probably a lot more emotionally
demanding than the experience for the
man and i feel like just a general
process of having someone else growing
inside of you so basically you've got
two people there there's like two people
there's already like double the
experience so that's kind of like my
logic there but i do like obviously like
male people are going through different
things i don't understand that because
i've not gone through the male
experience obviously you can have
thoughts and emotional issues going
around like i don't know
i mean with those like parent parenting
classes um it's usually parent like both
the parents and they work with both of
them about how to like
help the kid and the baby and you know
stuff like that i feel like maybe it is
and also like the dad still has the fear
like i feel like the thing about parents
is fear like it's fear of like
for nine months it better survive like
yeah like keep this going but
yeah so i feel like that sometimes
that's kind of diminished sometimes like
the looks like a mum caring but it's
like the dad is also like quite scared
about what's going on
i can appreciate that i heard this these
parents are like literally like when my
baby's sleeping sometimes i'm like
like i know you can't sometimes it's
like uh like
so like women go through so much after
pregnancy like memory loss
like a lot of women experience they
can't sleep like they have to be like
physically like barely sleeping so they
can always like hear their child like i
feel like that's like like having no
sleep is like scientifically known to be
like really bad for your health
so stuff like that like and also like
your pension you won't get a pension on
maternity leave for a lot of jobs so if
you take time off to take care of your
child you don't have a pension so that
then again like maternity leave too they
do but yeah like in some countries they
have a longer mentality but in most
countries they don't really have like a
long potentially so they can keep
working still earn a pension those kind
of things like more financial stability
going for the situation like there's a
woman if you're your partner you're
really dependent on them in that kind of
time well why is that a bad thing i'm
not saying it's a bad thing i'm just
saying it's like the biggest ability
that a woman has to go through higher
than that of a man in most situations
but isn't that kind of nice like if we
want you know you're 20 right
you date a guy 20 years older than you
you could like not work the rest of your
life if you want it like that's it
do you think you could do that one more
time
if she wanted to she could date a guy 20
years older than her and just like not
love her and i said like like would you
be able to do that you think the thing
is
the thing is
i think does anyone volunteer
which if anyone wants to do that for me
my dear friends are i believe that can
happen
don't get it i believe it can happen it
has happened and i know yeah i know
people that it's happened to
males yeah
but
that always comes with a cost
oh yeah oh for sure just like and that
cost you more time you you don't you
don't want to
you just don't
you don't want to um
spend the cost so basically
i
me personally mm-hmm
i wouldn't do it you wouldn't do it like
date like a really younger woman or like
when you yeah or older
i don't quite get an older guy and i
feel like people are like
20 years older because for me
okay not men's but
just let me say a childish man
if you're thinking about older women
you're thinking of a sugar man that's
really what you're thinking you're not
thinking oh i'm going to spend the rest
of my life because
if i'm 22
if i'm dating a woman half my age she's
44.
can i have kids
but like as a guy do you think okay like
role of us like if you was the older guy
and you're dating a twenty-year-old do
you think that woman wants to stay with
you for the rest of her your life
i am not doing that anyway so i i like
having like hypothetically like if that
was to happen
um i wouldn't say i don't think she
would want to stay
um
i think it depends but i i think 21 is a
little young but like like 20 like girls
my age if they dated a guy like 15 to 20
years older i think they'd want to stay
to be honest
i don't think there's like a genuine
energy there like i feel like when i
like the stereotype when a guy like like
when a woman dates older like a woman's
old and she did a young woman it's kind
of like more casual but the opposite way
around it's always like oh like she
she's just going there for money that
kind of stuff you know oh as in when the
the the the woman's younger yeah
what did you ask why what
why girls around my age who want to stay
yeah yeah
um well i just think like most 21 year
olds aren't thinking about marriage but
25 year olds like
would think about it more not all like
i'd say 25 to 30 like girls think about
getting married more than 21 to 25.
question yeah
when you say marriage
what do you think that is in this
21 year old's head
and let's say
35 year old woman's head
to actually have a marriage i'm talking
marriage for the rest of your life this
is the person i want to like okay what
goes into that because
for me personally like
even if i'm if it's just my girlfriend
if i'm not mentally attracted to you we
like we i can't i can't because it's
like what are we doing here we're just
together because you have big breasts on
us like that's what we're doing but i
don't think that's the case like always
i guess no no i'm not saying that's the
case they happen to be 20 years older
and we actually do love each other i'm
not saying that's the case it's
literally it's i'm just saying that so
so what's i'm just trying to understand
what your question is
there you go um
so
what goes into that
what goes into marriage what goes into
murder so what's up
thinking of okay i want to marry okay
yeah so if i
was looking to like get married in the
next year let's say
i would probably look for someone with
similar values to me that would probably
be really big so um
seems like sort of upbringing same like
values believe like similar things and
then
um
i gotta be taller than me i'm tall
and i was superficial i just mean it
um but yeah i think values are really
big when you're coming to marriage so
like my parents are both like the same
politics same religion same like like
upbringing sort of and i think that's
helped because they've been married like
close to 30 years so yeah i have nine
siblings so there's like 10 of us
oh how many one of six oh for real oh
that's adult
basketball team
you're like
only people i know of like parents who
like stayed together i was like that's
rare
no it's um
no it's really rare actually um
i think it's harder in this day and age
because like women are kind of
incentivized to leave because you get
money yeah i think um like in today's
world like the values are married to
different like i feel like like 20 years
ago like people actually really took
marriage quite seriously like it was
actually like i want to personally get
married because i really love this
person and i believe in marriage a lot
of people like
today a lot of like casual relationships
are there like there's always
something else available to you that's
kind of not that mindset like you know
like after like world war ii there's not
many men around it's like you just marry
whatever man was there like i feel like
because the availability there's always
someone else there like
it kind of doesn't make you push you in
the direction like oh yeah i want to be
this one person like this monogamous
relationship for a long time everyone's
the same though
i'm not saying i'm not saying i'm just
like the percentage of people that want
it it's probably less what
oh sorry
what what were you gonna get like did
you have a follow-up question okay
um well it's um we're leaning more
towards polygamy these days yeah that's
true that's true
i don't understand it i'm not going to
add more people
yeah i can't understand it like do you
know how emotionally taxing that is like
i don't understand it so we did for most
of human history you know
yeah no you're true yeah it's true yeah
but at the same time the dna joined
today
the amount of things we have to do and
like oh yeah let's say we're in london
london is an expensive place
like even to get like an apartment it's
expensive so
let's say you got six wives you got
about six house houses you go back you
gotta buy
like and let's say this is a typical the
man buys everything let's just say
he's gotta go to one wife remember her
problems
go to another
her problems and then go to another wife
you might talk to one wife about the
otherwise problems and it's a whole no
that's long but that's like marriage
like if you're married to six wives
because i think of it as like three or
four people who are actually together
it's like not one person he goes to
different people and they don't know
about yeah that's like really
centralized well i think the
the polygamous relationships we're going
to see is like one guy with like
multiple girls and then one girl with
like multiple guys
because the way the dating market is
today it's like a very small percentage
of men have access to all the women and
so and then
and then there's like the but so it's
like 20 of men have access to 80 of
women and other 80 of men are fighting
over 20 of
roughly
women
women to like one man because because
now that women like make more money we
want a guy that makes more than us
and i've never understood that well
there's there's biological reasonings
for the reasons we feel the way we feel
so it's not necessarily all of our fault
so a big double standard i hear for like
women and men and someone submitted this
on my instagram is body count right like
if a guy sleeps with a lot of girls he's
more valuable a girl vice versa right
but the reason that is is because over
the course of human history like men had
to ensure paternity so they have but
biologically they can't really help
that they're attracted like
all this and you don't know it's your
child like yeah yeah and it's we're in a
different time now because we have birth
control so that completely changed the
game but we didn't have that over the
course of human history we can't ask men
to just change their biology that's how
they feel and it's the same thing with
women because we had to find the highest
possible mate that we could
so in over the course of human history
like you wanted a guy that had slept
with more girls because that like then
he would have been able to protect those
girls it was a form of pre-selection
does that make sense and it's the same
thing with um income we want a guy
that's more competent than us so he
could protect us and take care of it
and that's why the second guy that yeah
right and i'm not saying it's realistic
in this day and age because like women
are making more and more money there's
only so many men but that's why we see
polygamy because girls would rather
share a guy that makes more money than
have a god that's not really then that's
like they feel is below them okay
i think um yeah
this is a question that not a lot of
people ask what do you guys think the
foundation of a relationship is i guess
trust
um like with trust and communication you
can pretty much i feel like that's why a
lot of people are scared of probably
polygamous relationships because in
monogamous relationships maybe they
can't manage this trust and communicate
on communication with like one person
one other person then to imagine like
multiple people can seem quite complex i
think that's why it's probably um
quite a scary thing for a lot of people
but i do see like it's the future of
like relationships
i think it's value added to be honest i
think like everyone every relationship
we have right
like even just friendships it's the
value you bring to each other's life so
me and you right we become best friends
after this
every single day right like the value
you know you i would bring to you is
maybe i'm entertaining i'm very
entertaining i'm funny too
and like the value you would bring to me
is like you're good listener right i do
have a follow-up question yeah so so
every every relationship is an exchange
of value and it they start to go south
when like one part partner like doesn't
bring that
yeah and so but the the problem is men
and women value different things so it's
hard to be on the same page
it's not hard to be on the same page but
i think women are confused
so like like girls will make a lot of
money and think that's attractive to men
but men don't really care it's like
nothing to them it's like a shoe
collection
like like if a guy has a shoe collection
or do you care
no no like it's like no that's like our
money yeah and so like girls will make
all this money and think oh all these
guys are going to want me but they don't
they're like yeah it's nothing yeah yeah
i understand that i understand how like
sometimes women have like like a false
perception of what men want yeah
relationship and like men also have like
a full potential of what women want
they're like like uh they want a woman
like a man thinks a woman wants certain
things that's but sometimes a woman is
like not even interested i don't think i
can go off of men and women as i said
before
human beings are all human beings and
we're all different
not everyone is is um
not everyone is confident enough to be
themselves
not everyone even knows who they are yet
let's say people aren't 18 19 20 21 22.
i don't even believe i know bear in mind
like i do know the certain certain
things but like words like integrity i
don't think a lot of 18 euros have that
they might change
in certain
uh
environments
but my follow-up question question was
do you guys believe that love is uh
unconditional
no no
you don't because there's always
something you can do that will like you
can there's there's a lot of extreme
things you can do that will prob pretty
much end a lot of like relationships
bear in mind i didn't say relationship i
just said love
yeah i don't think love is unconditional
right there's like phases of love like
when it's like at its peak and when it's
not
the only unconditional love is maybe
parent-child and even i know and i know
people that hate their parents and
parents that hate their kids so i would
even say that's conditional
i don't know the closest thing i would
say to unconditional
reason i said that is because
he was talking about what men and women
were in a relationship right
the woman will love you on the condition
that you do xyz
the man will love you on the condition
that you do xyz those conditions
are that man or woman's
uh perception of what a good
relationship is
does that make sense
yeah so that's why i said we can't just
say men and women because everyone's
different yeah so
let's say you don't you want a guy
that's shorter than you yeah and i know
you don't that's what i said
that's your that's what you want
and that's that's all you want yeah um
these six ten six eleven guys coming up
do you seven foot guys coming up you
talking about
do you wanna join a date yeah you're
gonna tell them no
but bear in mind like you
let's say they have everything else you
want
you're still going to say no because
that's the one thing that's the one
non-negotiable
that you are not going to negotiate like
listen i don't shrink and then maybe
like yeah yeah negotiation yeah at all
so
like
for us to say
men and women we can't even
begin because every time i
listen to podcasts or hear these type of
conversations in my head i'm like
everyone's not the same because i've met
different type of guys i have different
types of one different oh oh for sure
for i think you think about attraction
but we but we this is this is what i
always say on my podcast we can't we
would go all day if we talk about the
specifics we always talk about in
general and in general if a girl's
really hot she dates a rich guy and if a
guy's really rich he dates a hot girl so
there's something to be said but that's
the problem we can't go off in general
the reason why i'm saying that i don't
get twisted i understand why yeah but
the reason why i'm saying that is
because when we go off of general then
certain problems
will never ever be will never never come
to surface like what
for instance okay um
[Music]
how liking a short guy like if that was
to happen you're like
if that was to happen
like that's
do you know how many other girls out
there like probably have a secret fetch
for short guys but don't want to say it
because no one else is saying it
actually that's a big thing of that's a
big thing in like in in in cell culture
i don't know if i'm not saying that but
you know those guys who are like really
like demonized who are you know like
yeah um like
women like they like hate women or
whatever um
like that's a big thing where like oh
women have all these expectations and
stuff about men and then they kind of
warp their minds to think
like that's a big thing like um that
they use against like weaponised women
yeah or like demonize them in feminism
well there is something interesting i
learned in psychology recently i did
like a couples therapy um like module in
my psychology course and basically said
that we look for people that give us
like the same pain or the most like if
we had a room full of people we would
choose the person to be a partner that
would give us like is capable of giving
us the most pain because we look for the
person that emulates the relationship
with our parents so a lot of our
attraction is not like always best
choice we don't always make like we
never really make the best choice i
think so we choose the person that
probably wouldn't listen to us the most
or have the most shared interests but
like fits the dynamic the emotional
dynamics
go off you not being educated enough
from your like as like of the type of
person you are because you haven't grown
yet i don't think it's like about
knowing yourself because i think this is
something like a subconscious level
because like you're trying to emma light
like this emotional relationship that
you've had with like your parents i feel
like that's something that you can't
control but i think it's just
interesting
i think it's just interesting that
people don't
see i think they misinterpret that i
think women are attracted to traits that
are good and bad no like like it's a two
it's a two-dimensional thing right
because we're attracted to men that are
very that make a lot of money right or
competent right so that that comes high
in the trait disagreeableness
so if a guy's more disagreeable he tends
to make more money that's why men make
more money than women because they're
more willing to negotiate for better
salaries and women will just be like oh
okay you know because we're more
agreeable than men on average
but on the other side of that like
prisoners are also disagreeable
so we're attracted to the same trait
that like makes one person a successful
businessman and one person a prisoner
and and so a lot of like the traits that
we like
it's like it's it's
well yeah because we're attracted you're
you're biologically attracted to a guy
that has slept with like more girls and
we can't really help that because no
girl wants a guy that nobody wants
like that's also for a
but he doesn't want a guy that like
everyone's had not everyone's cat but
like you want people to find your
girlfriend attractive for sure for sure
for sure yeah yeah
there's this interesting thing i heard
that's about sexual attraction and how
that's based off literally like
science-based it's based off like
what you want from your mate
out of your offspring because obviously
like love and all that and like
attraction it's all just like chemicals
to make you shag like to have spring
like like apparently
sexual attraction is just
like you when you're sexually attracted
to someone you want certain traits in
your childhood that makes sense though
like if you see someone that's tall
you're like oh yeah he could care and
protect oh yeah that makes like well
because you want the best like genetic
offspring especially especially women
like we want we want like good jeans
[Music]
well that's that's like the difference
because men
like historically they want it was the
quantity of women that they could
produce with and women it was the
quality of the gene yeah i think that's
also to do with like how long the woman
is pregnant for that the woman has to
take nine months to have this child it's
an investment no
higher than what the man has to invest
but that's why i think like birth
control changed the world and it changed
dating because
you have all these girls that are like
sleeping with a guy that they would
never get before yeah so like a girl
that's a four like a guy like a guy
that's a eight nine or ten will sleep
with a girl that's a four or five or six
you think like just because of
availability not every guy right but
like
just 20
no no i'm saying like there's there's a
good a good you know like look at
tristan thompson he's out here wild in
like
nick you know what i mean like yeah and
so these girls like think they're hot
enough to like get commitment but they
would like i would never commit to her
it's just sex but then the girl thinks
she's above like guys that are actually
like on her level none of you guys are
saying this uh do you believe uh
that guy is cheap because of sex because
they're just odd because of emotions or
sex i think it's like a biological thing
i think there's a lot of like i feel
like a lot of people have that like
you're not receiving the validation that
you need in your relationship so you
have to go elsewhere to find something
that you're missing so i think it
happens in like a relationship that's
probably not stable or there's something
missing like maybe you're going through
something and you can't talk to like
your partner and you want to find that
emotional connection with someone else
or you're not having sex in this
relationship you want to find that
somewhere else something's like missing
from the relationship that you're in so
it's like you're not healthy so what if
you spot it again the guy was like you
know what i just wanted to have sex like
i love my girlfriend but i just wanted
to have sex oh what if the guy said that
to you i'm like that's a bit
disrespectful my yeah my personal thing
is perfect with the girlfriend you could
like you can always literally say like
what if we were
like polyamorous like what if we did you
know like say oh but if we want to tuck
up with different people
and then like at least have that
conversation but if you're
getting of other people and then lying
that's cheating that's wrong
if you don't even have that conversation
and then kind of and i think especially
with married people which is the big
thing that people talk about with
cheating is like married people and then
they cheat with people
um it's like you could have at least had
that conversation and it's been like
maybe if we were you know open and more
you know like
i think it's that thing of like if you
don't at least have that conversation
it's just like cowardly to me personally
no i i agree but i do think men and
women cheat different like i think i
think men
like i i think men are more able to like
just sleep with a girl and like forget
and just like it's just like
what makes me think that because men and
women like you guys are programmed to do
that
like like
genetically you guys wanted to spread
your seed as much as possible
historically
where women had to find the best quality
mate and so you know there has to be
like we don't just forget our genetics
overnight just because we have birth
control nowadays so how would a woman
cheat that's different to a man like
what's the how would you because i think
when a girl cheats usually the guy is
like better like
someone that's like okay like tradition
like films and stuff like they'll be
like a guy that's maybe more successful
yeah yeah where the guy will like like i
always say this on my podcast when i
when girls realize they have to be like
worried about the ugly girls too
and it's true because because guys we'll
cheat with a girl they that's not even
they're not attractive
because you know like how many girl guys
do you know that cheated and you're like
he cheated with her
over because it's not about that for
like
yeah it's just about uh it's just a set
you know i think it's you know
as a guy you should be open with what
you're trying to do but then most girls
can't handle it either yeah i do think
it's a bit taboo i don't think a lot of
people are ready like let's say in a
relationship and you're monogamous and
you've never talked about uh being a
polygamous before and like who's gonna
bring up the conversation first like
that's a tough topic to bring up
i i think it's the action of the action
of cheating like when you choose to do
that you're betraying that trust me oh
i'm with you yeah but if you have that
conversation
like i don't think cheating is right but
at least if you have that conversation
like and then establish like oh this is
her but then if you cheat i think she's
wrong but like at the same time like
you like
if you have um that conversation you can
avoid having this betrayal yeah and then
maybe you could just like get with other
people but then like the risk is there
so like let's say
someone's in a relationship like whoever
brings us up this could be the end of
the relationship yeah like but i didn't
want this and then it's like
then where'd you go from there i think
it's interesting from like a like gay
perspective because there's a lot of the
things of like
like closeted straight guys who are
married and they're like oh this is the
i think in this day and age in here in
britain like and like space is like
you can kind of like you should just
come out like i get there's there's like
cultural things and stuff but at the
same time i'm kind of like you could at
least have that conversation where
you're like maybe we could you know or
at least divorce them and then be like
oh i'm seeing like this yeah what do you
think so what do you think about people
that like pretend to be straight like
don't have a wife to have kids i think
yeah they're actually they've not
they've known they're gay it's not fair
especially in modern day like it's not
fair on the wife to cheat on them and
then be like oh like at least divorce
them
and then kind of like i just personally
i don't know maybe my head's just weird
but like in my head i'm like you would
at least just kind of like be like this
relationship isn't working and then
divorce them and then because they're
still cheating i think yeah when it's
get even if it's like oh you're in a
family that would never accept that and
in some cases would just disown you you
could at least i don't know like i think
it's a difficult situation to navigate
but like especially in like england i
feel like yeah it's a safe enough space
yeah yeah yeah
it's not to marry someone and pretend
like you like this what's the short face
for you oh my god hold on i gotta pause
this guys
this is the biggest super chat i have
ever gotten on this channel thank you so
much to zenny's for the 300 super chat
okay
so
um three he had three messages so the
first is a woman has to bear the
physical burden of
well-being which includes body changes
which lasts nine months but men have to
bear the financial burden to the family
for 18 plus years however men don't
glorify what they do they just do it
because of the understanding of their
role
a woman
um
because of love because of love
another one
pension during maternity leave if you
own a business would you pay someone for
not working it isn't and it is the
woman's burden to bear the child and
provide and protect the man these days
women are shrinking their role
a five dollar super chat from black ups
a lot of babies are birthed against a
man's will but he takes financial
responsibility she can just give up the
baby for adoption no questions asked
twenty dollars from dentists moderate
moder modern modern
um modern women's equality is equity
during peaceful times but when war or
high
oh this is a good one modern woman's
equality is equity during peaceful times
but when war or hardship comes they're
they are petite delicate things they
can't do what men do all of the sudden
that's true i think all the women were
doing when the men were at war like
farming and stuff like we did lots of
industries
yeah
no
people will talk about that um two
dollars the difference is men don't talk
about their fears uh thank you who's pet
cub five dollar from black ops equity
gives women an unfair advantage equity
will mean the male and female basketball
players get paid the same even if they
bring in less money
from two dollars from petco life isn't
fair five dollars from black ops the
problem is that feminists are only
eyeballing the ceo jobs in positions of
power and never lower and never for
lower performing jobs
okay i think that's everything you're
done yeah because i actually i'm sorry
go ahead i watched this thing this
morning actually funny enough that was
it was actually a really horrible show
but netflix like
liquidated me with this really good
scene where this woman she was like a
university speaker and she was saying
like oh so i'm teaching this thing and
it's like a female like primary course
and i just want to you know female
females in economics and she's basically
talking about like feminism and
performative um like you know
there's a difference between women who
what moan on twitter about inequality
and women who go out there and try and
get these positions that they moan about
not getting
and um
kind of i thought that was very
interesting i think there is a
difference like people are actually like
trying to get to a job and they're
getting the frustrations okay it's got
to be like because i'm a woman that i'm
not getting this job and obviously like
you have a different experience and i'll
stop you
yeah hold the thought though
i was watching something this morning
yeah um
it made a lot of sense a lot of sense
and i just want to know you guys opinion
on it so
there was this woman
she went to picasso picasso because it
was the paint all right just
yeah okay
i'm dumb no he does do pain
um
so this woman comes out to picasso uh
she says oh my gosh you're my favorite
um
artist
can you draw me something he gave she
gave him a napkin oh the napkin i've
heard
him she's giving him a napkin and he's
drew something and then he said to the
woman
um something like that's five thousand
pounds now please yeah and she said what
for just for that she was like and he
was like yeah just for that
and then at the end of it it said
that took him five minutes to do
but took him probably five years to
perfect to even do it in five minutes
and bear in mind that's his job that's
his profession so now
i want to know you guys opinion on that
also
doesn't matter the job because that's
bear man that's his profession that's
what he decided he wanted to when
picasso was like alive probably women
weren't allowed to be doing [ __ ] like
that picasso wasn't that old by the way
well i thought he's in like the i think
it's 1800 i think it's like 16. i don't
i don't understand the question
so like he's he's basically saying i've
put yeah as much amount of working
for this much amount of time
just to be able to yeah to be able to do
this in five minutes this is going to
cost you because you've just spent
you've just used my time oh yeah i
actually kind of relate to that because
people will always ask me like oh how'd
you build this platform did it like and
they want you know my help like for free
often
but i've spent two years working for
nothing pretty much
yeah yeah yeah like because especially
in social media you have to be willing
to do it for free for like kind of a
while so
yeah i i think you should i think anyone
has the right to charge whatever they
want but
will people buy is the question yeah
what does this lap can even look like
like if you i'm not sure how like
picasso is not my favorite so i could
have been like a doodle so i can see
where she's going from a little bit yeah
yeah cubism yeah i don't know if it was
serving no one was picasso do you really
think it was just like a little squiggle
like i don't know if you seen picasso
it's really pretty abstract stuff like
it could have been something that like
did you spill your coffee on that like i
don't know
who knows but like i get i get like the
the moral of the story like a lot of
work goes into something and you can't
just expect like because it was done in
this short period of time that it
doesn't have value exactly so i do think
that's important that's why that's like
because um
what did you say you said something
about um
the uh about
how much time you've put in
and how much money you should get you
said something wrong along the lines i
said
that
um anyone has the right to charge what
they want but the question is what like
what will people buy i also said i were
you i worked for like two years for free
basically how was that actually
awful i just stay motivated like okay
this is definitely what i'm doing i'm
doing the right thing like i would
question myself i'm really like because
everyone that i watched on social media
that made it said that they had to work
for free effort so you said okay this is
just part of the process yeah they said
three to five years work for free so you
you've made a shortcut you're doing that
pretty well that's interesting because i
work
not well enough send me a super chat
also guys all super chats are gonna be
donated for a second camera like when we
talk wouldn't it be nice to get like a
close-up of our faces
with a simple donation
you know
and maybe next month
also for new mic so we have four mics
now i want to get eight and i want to
get a second sound board we're at about
like 500 i need about like a thousand to
get the second set of mics
another
one i'm like questioning is this dollars
i was like wait is this a different
currency um it could be rupees i don't
know i'm like oh no no
i was like i think i oh i know i think
it's a hundred dollars i think
i'm like okay maybe i don't know thank
you anyways i'm still excited regardless
women who cry about equality and ceo
positions never address the fact that
those positions are a zero-sum game
meaning
someone must lose for another one to get
it where's the quality no equality for
that hard work and dangerous jobs
careful your privilege is showing what
do you think of that
i do think um
i know personally if like a ceo job is a
very difficult job yeah personally i
wouldn't want to be in that country
because i know what kind of work it
takes like you're going to be available
all the time answering emails and
holidays and stuff that's kind of not my
world but like if someone's going to go
into that and be like oh like as a woman
i'm just going to get this job because
i'm a woman i've worked hard but just
because i'm a woman i should have the
extra ex
i don't know if that counts like i think
there's minimal things like you know
that uh thing you had where it's like
women in coding and stuff like
small things but when it comes to ceo i
don't think there are things that are
like positions for women in seattle like
ceos like you've got here will give you
a chance i don't think those top
positions i have those kind of again i'm
not like
i think they do
i think that when like like people want
women in positions of power so they can
market it like you realize 80 percent of
consumer buying decisions are made by
women also women hold 80 percent of like
credit card debt
like women so everything we see in
society is like constantly being
marketed to women for women
like do you do you think like men want
to see like plus-sized girls
that's what i mean like yeah
i personally don't know a lot about that
what do you mean plus i saw girls like
in advertisements yeah like that's for
women that's not for men like when
politicized women are modeling it's
normally for women's clothes so i'm not
sure if that would appeal to a man
anyway like it's a bikini oh for sure
for sure
and then that gets into that yeah but
yeah but they get they go to the cover
of like even sports illustrated
experience is different like um i don't
know but i like sports and plus size i'm
not sure like i haven't met many plus
size athletes before so i'm not sure
like yeah which is no my only point is
that like everything we see in the
market is for women so
i would guess and this is this isn't
this is just you know feeling not based
on data or anything like if there was a
male ceo and a woman ceo they would pick
the woman because they can market that
especially if they're a big company
like bumble like the whitney whatever
her name is yeah she only owns like 10
of the company and they all talk about
she's a female ceo yeah yeah
yeah i guess it is like i think we're
just in a very performative age like a
lot of it's like showing people like
correct like yeah you see it around like
there's like a small event or like let's
say it's like pride month or like
yesterday then all of a sudden like
everything changes the colors are
different and yeah it's like a company's
just trying to show like yeah i'm
interested in this one in reality it's
like a big marketing thing yeah it's
always a marketing thing valentine's day
yeah like is that yeah that's so
important
[ __ ]
i think valentine's day is a bit cringe
to be fair yeah like monster time
father's day i'll do it like i think
mother's day is a bit cute like i do
like it's good to recognize your parents
but like i feel like like mother's day
father said i've never really been like
bombarded with like messages
like let's say you have a boyfriend yeah
do you need to be reminded to love your
boyfriend
no i don't like valentine's day mother's
day father's day is like it doesn't
think about it
for me personally
yeah and i'm speaking for myself um
i'm not gonna wait until valentine's day
to go and bring my girlfriend to a hotel
and be like i love you listen if i know
you then i am going to show you this
every day yeah
that's a big thing about relationships
in general like marriage a lot of people
say the thing you need to do to keep a
marriage surviving is treating it like a
new
like not letting go and just being like
oh this is a normal day like being
boring about like
like kind of well what's the word like
rejuvenating the relationship once in a
while like not just like igniting it
yeah like and giving those special like
things once in a while instead of just
like so you think the valentine's day is
kind of like a reminder of that like
like a birthday like we love our friends
but on their birthday like oh shower you
would love buy you a cake buy your
parents a gift it's like really a day
about this person also it's like there's
anniversaries and stuff for that and
it's like
do you think it's okay to say things
like men are trash
i feel like yes and i have a reason
because okay why
statistically like men have been trashed
for so long
for so so long i'm talking beginning of
time
you know like that kind of like for so
long men have been doing like really bad
stuff like saying men in trash like
mental trash is okay but i do feel like
you know like you're going to be like in
a jokey way you've got to be like okay
like this is not like i don't really
mean like you're trash like you're like
okay so what if what if guys said women
are [ __ ]
like in a joking way
like personally but they they kid you
know what i mean i think is that it's
kind of in the same plane like it's in
the same domain like the same kind of
you really do you think people would
have the same reaction so if i said men
are trash and he says women are [ __ ]
like do you think it'd be the same like
you know fair enough
you know what's weird because if someone
was like that's very weird because if
someone said women [ __ ] i'd be like
ooh if someone said yeah no but if
someone said women are hoes i'd be like
okay like that's very different
yeah yeah
there's this i don't you're american so
i don't know yeah you know like degrassi
where they were like i i'm sure that's
canadian yeah
like there was this thing where it's
like tears claire i didn't know you
could get such a yeah i didn't know you
could get that from a [ __ ] and everyone
was like oh my god he called our whole
life yeah i remember this whole thing
that's very weird because like i call my
clothes female friends [ __ ] and it's
like oh my god you [ __ ] like but like
when it's like that we're like i think
especially straight men and it's like oh
you're a [ __ ] like or like women always
it's like i just do i just don't
understand like why do we make all men
pay the price for a small percentage of
men like why don't you see what you said
yeah you see what you said about
the question yeah i said um is it okay
for uh guys to say well enough yeah and
then women's the same managers
so
think about like this show
if women and correct me if if you guys
disagree in my opinion if women
say to men oh men are trash we're going
to just going to look at you and blah
okay yeah yeah
some guys do get take it personally
they're like
nobody but it's not
the majority of the guys we're gonna
look at you in black okay that's all
we're gonna say bear in mind we're
probably thinking a bunch of things but
wasn't that okay yeah but if we call if
i go on the street right now obviously
go to a random woman not random woman
but let's just say i go to
someone i kind of knew
you're a [ __ ] she's gonna blow up like
like i feel like she would blow up those
are two very different i mean this is a
difference i feel like women say men are
trashed like their faces a lot and it's
kind of like in that realm of like yeah
like ah men are trash like a man a man
would like to another man like that
woman's a [ __ ] it's more like like no
but i'm talking about saying it to them
because usually when women say men are
trash they are saying they say to your
we're going to have a fight like and not
it's not the guy a fight and a woman is
going to be the woman trying to fight a
guy like
we
don't care as much do you think men
aren't trash i think everything is trash
i think everybody is a hypocrite i don't
think women are better than men
because you're acting you're acting like
men are on a lower like moral high
ground than women because men men also
built the world like the worlds we're
living and men built that's kind of
different though because it's kind of
like women didn't have the chance to
build the world like the kind of the
roles that we had in that position
i personally feel like that's a pact
okay do you
but like even men still run the world
today and we have the opportunity now
women aren't building infrastructure
they're not building the buildings
they're not doing the plumbing they're
not doing the electric they're not doing
all the things that make society run
what do we do marketing we do
people-to-people jobs that are expect
like men still run the world
so like
like even even you're talking about like
men like did all the atrocities they
also
were the ones like doing the great
things too i'm not saying like women are
like completely innocent in the whole
world and like everything that happens
on the concept of society i think that
like i do think there's like many
instances that men have been trashed and
i've liked to say it it isn't that
politically incorrect i don't think it
is but there's also many instances where
women have been trashed yeah absolutely
so so
so like there's there's instances where
women put send men to jail where they go
to jail for false like great accusations
so so why why is one acceptable like why
like calling a woman at a [ __ ] it's not
the same as calling a woman trash so you
can call a woman trash that's fine i
call it a man trash is fine but that's
what the horse
yeah completely like degrading yeah it's
like it's a different source like what's
called a manner
that's what i mean like women going
around called men [ __ ] yeah that's
what i was gonna say because there's a
lot of times women like [ __ ] [ __ ]
scare oh actually oh yeah like yeah like
there's a lot especially in britain yeah
yeah and it's like with men there's like
a dick there's like
like [ __ ] yeah yeah yeah like
professional and that's very recent and
like a lot of and it's like if you say
[ __ ] it's like a manhole and it's very
i think that's interesting not like like
socially i think that's interesting like
how many words linguistic there is like
degrade a woman in comparison to a man
well i think men are trash that's like
like a woman's a [ __ ] it's like oh
that's like there's a different plot
there's a different like menotrash it's
like men exist and they're horrible like
men yeah exists before and then women
like a woman's a [ __ ] that's like she's
promiscuous and horrible and that's like
a that's like a historically like
demonizing thing for women but at the
same time men are trash is like
but should we be demonizing women for
being promiscuous
but men of trash is like demonizing men
for like existing yeah
calling a man trash is like demonizing
him for being for doing bad things but
calling a woman [ __ ] is like humanizing
her being promiscuous and being
promiscuous shouldn't be demonized
anymore well
no when you say men are trash like
people just say that to say it it's not
even for it's not even like for doing
bad things i've said that after having a
bad day like she yeah yeah
and even and even like
i mean i i i think society would be
better if women didn't sleep around as
much actually you think so yeah what do
you mean by that though especially if
women sleep around enough then there
wouldn't be any children oh men only
have that's not true that's not true
women are having more sex than ever and
there's less kids than ever so women
have more sex than men that'll be
soreness of you yeah i do agree with
that like
yeah yeah but if women stop having like
sex then men will stop having sex you
know what i mean that's kind of like no
no
i'm not saying stop having sex but like
i feel like as women we try to like
reframe stuff
so it's like oh we don't like that
there's a double standard right with the
with the body count and sleeping around
whatever and we try to change the
definition but people feel how they feel
about it and there's a reason things are
the way they are
like it doesn't it doesn't benefit women
to sleep around it like because less
guys want to date you the more like if
you like no guy wants to get with a girl
that's you want to go with a date a girl
wife or girl that slept with all your
friends
no yeah yeah
yeah i guess that is true but in my life
like dated all my friends either
there you go
it's like we lie to each other though
because as girls we know deep down that
like it's not appealing to guys if we
sleep around we know that and so why do
we tell each other that that it is i
think it's like coming from the idea
from the beginning like this idea of
femininity or like feminism is like
being like the man to be respected and
to be like at the same level to be equal
i'm going to start acting like a man in
the way like i'm going to be right no
that's that's yeah yeah that's exactly
we're going to be equal someday but i
don't think it's like that but i feel
like it's just like a product of that
kind of feminism no and it's and it's i
think it's harmful to women because you
give these girls this bad advice
even though we and it's and it's it's
hard because we know like you know deep
down that like that's sleeping around
has consequences it's more for women
than for men but we still tell the
younger generation of women to do it why
um i do notice a lot like in media like
sleeping around is kind of like a big
thing like for women like now like i see
i'm taking like women like everyone like
sex work and things like that i don't
know how healthy it is especially for
young audiences right and like the main
people and the idea they're trying to
say like sex work is real work no it's
not
why are we
[Music]
it should be demonetic i'm sorry because
i think it's bad advice to the next
generation
yeah like
i think it's just dangerous advice i
feel like yeah yeah especially like
people on tick tock like what what is
like the like main age range like an app
like that like maybe like 13 or 15.
yeah like they're seeing that kind of
content i don't think it's healthy no i
agree i'm like okay i'm thinking that
that's normal because i see it so often
yeah like maybe sex work is like
easy or fun i don't think it's like
realistic because when i think of sex
work like that's like a last resort as
someone who's like that i'm not going to
get into it but yeah he's like done it
that is like last resort it's like no
it's not like something like you're a
child you don't that shouldn't be
and how many girls turn 18 and start an
only fast yeah i think before they're
18. but we're in this society where we
say don't judge no judgment whatever
because you know i think
especially as women there's a part of us
that like we want people to feel
included and we have empathy and i think
that's a good trait but like it goes too
far because we start lying to each other
there's a cause there's a big cost more
for women than for men to do and only
fans
i do feel like it's like very enabled
like men's i don't feel like men are
like in a part like responsible for this
like increasingly they're the audience
like there's not a lot of women there
like oh yeah like
we they're not like saying they want
women to be that way but like you watch
like videos well that's because women
are portrayed
but we don't tell we don't tell young
women there's a difference between a
sexual attention and relationship
attention like you can go like i could
go take off my clothes tomorrow and go
on instagram and get a ton of sexual
attention but would any of those guys
want to marry me yeah and so it's a
different kind of value yeah right and
that's what i'm saying like like these
conversations we don't have with like
the younger young girls and so they get
confused because they think by like
doing the sex work taking off their
clothes and being more promiscuous more
guys will want them and they will in the
short term
empowering when it's like it's but it's
also kind of dangerous but yeah
and yeah there are girls that start only
fans when they're under 18 and they get
themselves and other people in trouble
romanticize i feel like they shouldn't
have romanticized this whole sex work
thing i just don't think you should
someone else says i do think it's
romanticized that you see it in lots
films sugar daddy he's taking care of me
like people like of
but that's a really dangerous
environment for a young woman and and
and they also lie because they'll say
they have to do nothing to get which is
it's a lot they're gonna get messages
and messages can be explicit i don't
think that's nothing i feel like you're
gonna be receiving and not even that
like the girls that talk about they get
sugar daddies and they'll claim they
don't have to sleep with him
for how long
cause no guy is gonna be funding your
whole life just a chat just just to hang
out with you there's there's nothing is
free
but i just as girls we like lie to each
other it's the same thing with the body
positivity movement and i think it comes
from a place of empathy right because we
don't we don't want people to feel
excluded and like we have that like
motherly
you know part of us but it's lying to a
girl to say you're gonna get more
options with guys by gaining weight like
if i gained 100 pounds i'm sorry the
guys that are interested in me today
probably wouldn't be i think that's
different though because i think that's
in terms of media that's something where
a lot of people were like it's a thing
of like
skinny girls and girls at work like
there's different spring being fat and
being bigger and like like bigger girls
were like kind of categorized into fat
and categorized into oh ha ha look at
her she's fat no wants to get with her
and i've actually seen the effects of
that into younger women and i think plus
sized
positivity positivity is a somewhat good
thing i think there's a difference
between plus size and like obc and like
dangerously like big
like in terms of like
representation
yeah but like also like i think yeah
it's just that thing of like the
difference between plus size and obese
where it's affecting your health and
affecting yourself no i i actually agree
because i like you know i'm built like
an athlete like i'm i'm tall right so
like i remember the early 2000s like
white chicks you know the movie
no but all the girls in there it's like
they're so skinny and i'm just not like
built like that so i get what you're
saying but now like if i googled plus
size model do you think the majority
would be obese or do you think they
would just be an athlete like thick
and i think yeah i'm not talking about
like someone who is kind of like fat but
they're not like like it's not affecting
their health it's not affecting them as
a person if they want to be
like that they shouldn't have to the
point where there are you know like eds
and suicidal tendencies and stuff that
like affect their lives just like you
know like just because i've seen that
with people you know from social media
or media or stuff
like i've seen that happen where someone
who is you know like i'm not you know
i'm not gonna out them whatever but like
there's i've seen someone who because of
uh the expectations of someone on what
their body should be like they've been
kind of really like down on themselves
that's why i say i think a lot of these
movements come out of a place of empathy
that's what i'm saying like i think it
comes out of a place of empathy where
you know like i kind of relate to that
with what i was saying earlier
because you know i was always healthy
when i was younger but
you know i just think i agree with you
not yet but but i'm saying now like even
even what you're saying where they're
fat and it doesn't affect their health
it doesn't affect their health while
they're young
but but when they turn 40 is is it gonna
be the same
and it's like lying by where we're like
putting these girls on the covers and
almost encouraging
body positivity saying guys will still
like you but it's like the guys you
don't want are going to like you
[Music]
with what you're saying yeah i have a go
ahead
question um
what do you guys think about the word
communication but in
not media not so much media but in
your immediate circles your families
what do you think about the word
communication like what do you think
that
is wrong with it and what do you think
is good
i mean can i go first because i think a
big thing about my family is
um
a lack of communication has caused a lot
of like
problems with like
how people interact with each other how
people see each other
and interact with each other and i think
i don't yeah like i don't like
communication i think is very important
for
any relationship even if it's small or
big like
did you mean it's in like terms of a
relationship like what was like the
direction you wanted to go i just meant
that in terms of all right cool so this
is
this is let me tell you guys where i
asked the question now because
you also you guys were talking about um
how it looks to the younger generation
and the conversations that you need to
have with the younger generation how do
you mean like to be real like just being
direct like this is how the reality of
it is like don't like yeah okay and my
thing is
the reason why
in my opinion the reason why so many
things happen today only fans that
look
loads of things loads of things the
reason why those things happen today is
because
of a lack of communication certain
people
um might go and do
i don't know dye their hair yellow
because
of a lack of communication i don't think
it's a lack i think it's just the wrong
communication i feel like people like
yeah like do it you know but that's why
that's communicating
you you imagine you imagine you have a
daughter um and your daughter asks and
let's say hypothetically you've done on
your fans before
your door is like i want to do i want to
do only fans
um and let's say that that only fan
experience for you was embarrassing key
word uh embarrassing
not a lot of people want to communicate
when they're embarrassed when they're
when they um don't feel comfortable when
they
are wrong like not a lot of people like
to communicate then and
what i see is a lot of people are wrong
a lot of people are embarrassed a lot of
people are all these words but never
once want to tell someone okay listen
listen i did that but i did that because
i was feeling this way
like so there's communication but i'm i
think i'm also
leaning towards the side of
communication of how you feel
of what you did yeah i do think like a
lot of people like yeah i went through
that but like like i have parents i'm
like oh it's telling you've got to be
careful listen do these things i went
through this i know what it's like to be
a teenager vice versa but they don't
tell you exactly what they did and what
the experience was and i feel like if
they just told me straight like oh i
went through this and this this is how
this happened i'd be a bit more
respectful and bit like i'd listen more
i feel like people like yeah i went for
like a difficult experience like tell me
exactly what you went through and then i
can actually like appreciate what
happened and like use that in the future
to me this sounds like this reminds me
of misinformation like the idea of like
oh yeah only fans it's like yeah it's
not like people can screenshot any fans
which they can and leak that online or
like you know in the terms of like sex
work and stuff or like um
yeah like the idea of like oh like oh um
communication and they forget to mention
the downsides of stuff like that yeah
well i think a lot of people i think one
people lie
so like i think it's like a dishonesty
thing
where it's like the same thing it's not
out of a place of you know it's out of a
place of empathy with the body
positivity you know when we're saying
you're beautiful you're fat like even
though less people are attracted to you
when you gain weight you know both sides
like men and women
um
but i think it's the same thing with
only fans like a lot of times we just
like lie and act like there's no
consequences out of a place of not
wanting to like judge them you know i
feel like it's just like the social
media like how it's built like you're
not gonna go on instagram and post like
an ugly pic of yourself saying would
like to take job you're gonna post a
video like yeah yeah like i was nearly
like attacked or but this happened
yeah
yeah i think there's a fine line between
them
when it comes to instagram or
any type of social media there's a five
line between
using it for
a business purpose or a purpose it
doesn't matter what the purpose is
and then just using it does that make
sense like like just like okay i don't
care what i post i'm just going to post
because i i think we all have friends
that one friend that does not care they
have like a thousand pictures
and of them they're they're they're
they're
like everything yeah yeah yeah and these
pictures are imperfect pictures these
are not perfect pictures i like that i
kind of don't yeah but
the the the pages you see that pop up on
your screen mostly are these pages that
are well organized like curated like
everything exactly organized it might be
a nice beautiful woman on the the front
page or man whatever wherever it may be
like you're going to see all of these
things and these things are
lies
i don't know it's lies i just think it's
like really curated so it's just like
not realistic so it's just like really
like not statistically correct like in
real life you would not see that many
beautiful women go to like this event
you will not see like
this many people have the perfect coffee
every day like i just like the
availability of certain things this is
like really unrealistic so you don't see
like in real life you see okay this bad
thing happened or this good thing
happened there's not like that balance
it's like 90 good things happen on
instagram tick tock like positive
experiences you don't really have that
like let's talk about the downsides of
like sex work downsides of only fans
like all these stuff i think she's a
good availability thing because that's
how like social media works you want the
best image it's like marketing you want
the best image for like yourself and if
it's like you're marketing yourself
you're not going to market the bad sides
of yourself i think it's just like a
course a byproduct of that i'm not
saying it's good or bad but it's just
like how it works
and like a lot of people playing to that
because like why would i want to post
about instagram picture because like
what does who benefits from that and
then that's where the miscommunication
comes in yeah that's true like i could
post about page like yeah like sometimes
i don't
wear makeup something yeah but like
people should know that like if i
take it with a pinch of salt like it's
fake like it's so what you guys as
females
what should you guys um think or uh
opinion on
[Music]
taking pictures and posting them with
makeup on and taking pictures and
posting them
naturally like like do you want to go to
catfishing or you're talking about like
that
just in general i use makeup i wear
eyeshadow and stuff like this see but
that's it do you is that for pictures or
is that for you that's because i think
it looks cool but like that's that's
interesting though like do you think
they do it differently then because
girls like me personally i'm never gonna
lie to you i've seen
like
girls that look completely different
without makeup on when i say completely
different i mean completely different
like you wouldn't recognize them
and i know those people in per in person
and
to see that it's like whoa like
for me as let's say of you or a fan of
that person
to see you
with all your makeup and then that's not
you it's like well did you sell me a
dream this whole time
think
what do i do no do i unsubscribe do it
yeah yeah yeah that's interesting i
barely wear makeup so
i think like
i think it's um
about like feeling beautiful so like if
someone doesn't look conventionally
attractive should they be allowed to
feel beautiful by wearing makeup i think
that's a good question like society's
saying like society says like women
should wear makeup regardless of what
you look like they're saying to people
that don't feel confident themselves
they shouldn't be allowed to feel
beautiful so i think that's how like
that direction goes but on the other
side like
i do think makeup can be very deceptive
it can be well a lot of it is deceptive
yeah and the only reason i ask that is
because most people like for instance
like you said before if a girl takes
picture her top off puts on instagram
you're going to get a bunch of attention
but it might be the attention that
you're looking for so it's like do how
do you go about that now do you
post natural pictures of you of how you
really are every day or do you post
the way them pictures okay this is the
way i've thought about this okay this is
why this is why i don't wear a lot of
makeup like at all
one because i'm lazy i can't keep up
with the trends it's just too much for
me i i'm trying to run a youtube show
but second second because if i date a
guy like i would never want him to like
see me without makeup and like
like get a guy that i'm not supposed to
get almost because i'm caking yeah yeah
because i i don't like it when people
see you and they're like well what
happened you know i just would never
want that reaction
where i would rather not wear a lot and
then occasionally wear a lot and then
it's like oh like that's nice
rather than doing that every day yeah
yeah because i don't know i always
this was bad actually when i
when i was younger and i was on like
dating apps i'd always try to make
myself like look uglier because because
that way it'd be like a pleasant
surprise
i'm not saying this is a good strategy
probably not but it is
genuine yeah yeah because i was like i
don't want to get a guy that i'm not
supposed to get you know like i want the
guy to be attracted to like to my act
like the way i look
and
yeah so i think
girls i don't except they would always
say take her to the beach you know like
go swimming yeah
i think there's like a middle ground i
feel like there's like yeah i i agree
with this like putting on a lot of
makeup that will actually change like
the way you look yeah like enhancing
your own features
you don't you don't seem to wear a lot
like it seems light right yeah yeah
if i try to do foundation like number
one i would be wouldn't find a color
that matched my skin tone yeah yeah but
like sometimes i just don't like the
look of foundation well and if i don't
wear makeup it forces myself to eat
better because if my skin's bad
i'm more i'm more motivated to like
actually fix it oh my god i did a tic
tac today and i showed my skin like six
months ago it was so red
but then i was like then but because i
don't i can't cake stuff on one i don't
have the skill you know i'm just not
good at it but
yeah but two um i just i feel like it's
easier just to fix your skin than to
learn how to do makeup every day i think
that's a good point like i think like um
from the house side like if you wear
makeup you won't notice if you have like
you've not been sleeping if you wear
concealer every day you won't notice it
and your friends around won't notice so
i'm like oh like are you tired like i
feel like it's good like to ask like are
you tired yeah and then you can like pay
attention to your health yeah and they
sleep more like i should go to the gym
or yeah you know yeah
like your body i think that's a good
thing
is that does that answer your question
it does yes
um okay we're gonna go through the super
chats guys
stop it but don't keep going but like
thank you this is the most super chats
i've ever gotten from a show
okay um
from maverick s body positivity only
applies for women and never for men men
who are fat are called out to be fat
that is not equality
drug dealers are not right for selling
drugs just because there's a demand for
it because men don't because men pay
doesn't mean women should sexualize
themselves thank you to black ops so
he's saying like earlier when we were
talking about only fans because she said
we'll master the concealer
you shouldn't do it um okay
maverick making cocaine legal and not
judging people who use cocaine will
never solve the problem that is the same
thing as female promiscuity 599 from
k-9xi promiscuous women
does not give
any good benefits to women men children
in society but a man will only become
promiscuous once a man becomes high
status high earner strong provider
twenty dollar super chat from zen tiance
the female guest is justifying use of
specific words depending on who is
saying it based solely on how she feels
about the word this is a prime example
of the rationalization hamster and over
overdrive
this the female guest is justifying the
use of specific words depending on who
is at saying solely based very is saying
based solely on how she feels about the
word this is a prime example of the
rationalization hamster and overdrive i
don't remember what this was about but
maybe like
he's trying to say like i'm only
reacting to how i feel about things yeah
but like isn't that the point
like i don't know i feel like i should
be saying my opinion and not just like
yeah no it's true yeah so we do in
podcasts we give the opinions nobody
asked for
but you're here right okay um black ops
men cheat at 28 and women cheat at 23
but women keep calling men cheats when
the difference is insignificant
you know what's interesting about that i
know a statistic from private
investigators that
usually
when
men come in to ask if because you know
most private investigators they were
cheating cases
most of the time it's the
men that are wrong and most time it's
the women that are right when they get a
private investigator to investigate
those cases there's a higher chance of
finding out that the manche and then the
woman maybe she's just better that's a
personal thing like just from two like
probably yeah that's like a general
statistic well i think
that women are better at getting away
with yeah yeah i'll probably just get
away with it better yeah like just based
on like what i've
no
stories no not not me i've never cheated
but um no i even like girls when we go
out to bars i'll see girls like twerking
on another guy i'm like would your
boyfriend like you doing that how do you
feel about that i i think it's wrong i
would never do that if i had a boyfriend
if you had a boyfriend yeah no well i
didn't i didn't even
imagine my last boyfriend like i didn't
even
like go out to be honest when i was in a
relationship certain cultures yeah i
think cultures are different i think
right i'm not talking about cultural
like i don't know like dances yeah yeah
if you you're with someone that comes
from a certain culture for instance
have said that every time i've i brought
the same example up yesterday
and it was the same like argument yeah
yeah
that's it seems to be like like there's
some festival in britain or something
yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah that i guess everyone like dances
on youtube move on do we dance again do
we move on yeah
is it is it face to face or the girls
like twerking sometimes it's face to
face sometimes
it doesn't matter it's all different i
think it's just like it's just a good
time i don't think it's supposed to be
like you're not gonna like try and find
like someone to marry at this event like
it's not like a dating event but do you
think it's a bit like if i found out
like my boyfriend was like going to
carnival i was dancing a lot of people
like intentionally i would feel
uncomfortable about that but i
understand it's like part of the culture
to dance yeah like
and it doesn't mean i mean if you go
let's say you if you've got a boyfriend
and or girlfriend
but if you guys if you got a boyfriend
and you have a boyfriend and
he's gone to carnival and he's white
he's danced with a bunch of other people
i know let's forget about dancing he's
just gone to carnival how are you
feeling about it i'm fine because i feel
like i understand what carnival's about
yeah i'm kind of okay he's going there
to do i'm kind of jealous i would not be
chilling i would be jealous
i am not the chill girlfriend that's
just like oh do it that is not me i'm
not gonna care
it's gonna be on the same like level of
like extrovertness like i'm like if
you're actually i'll get extroverted and
you're both gonna dance then it's like
not like okay like you danced with five
people
five people as well you know like
like yeah i'll be like i'll go with you
then what are you guys what are you guys
going there for if you're going with him
like i think but like you guys are going
to go there watch a bunch of people have
fun and then you know i don't want to
play singles event though i'd have to
see carnival to understand it oh boy we
should watch a video i'm going to
analyze this imagine outside like your
flat
imagine that whole road ram packed full
of people and
there's speakers and there's floats and
there's people dressed it's kind of like
thanksgiving parades okay yeah
thanksgiving that's the but like imagine
brazil if you're like these brazilian
dancers like dancing everywhere like
imagine there's like
like every like one in five racial
there's always like one great dance
that's like doing something crazy and
like dancing on everyone that's what
it's like like there's always like a
mini show like everywhere
i'm excited to hear what your first
experience are you gonna go to carnival
when is it when it's kind of working
it's in like summer
sometimes
observe but like maybe reaction videos
you should go like
no just people all i'm saying to you is
be prepared because for what what should
i prepare for like i do feel like
okay okay i have questions okay i got i
got questions am i gonna get groped you
are well then i want a girl
people will like dance on you i'm not
don't get interested if you get groped
it's not like come home with me is you
have an srs and then move on like that's
the kind of way it is that's different
but here's here's my thing okay i'm not
really a big grinder i like to shimmy
you know i'm not i'm
i'm not
i don't really dance that much but if i
do i'm like i do not i do not like
being all up on a guy that i don't know
okay i feel like that's why it's like a
cultural thing yeah
like it's kind of well not new to london
but like it's not traditionally british
to dance like that in germany i loved
the dancing in germany because there's
no guy trying to like grab your wig they
spin you around it's so cute
instead of like i'm like i do not want
to be
but like germany's different like the
music there is a lot different to the
music that we listen to here techno like
yeah dancing on song with techno but
it's like it's your own
i enjoyed i felt like german guys are so
respectful like they are they respectful
but like are they shy like it's like
young guys are like
a lot more introverted in comparison to
like british guys i would say probably i
don't i was 18. this was a long time ago
but
yeah when i was in germany i loved how
they danced because i just i'm just not
a
i'm a shimmy you're a guy
i do feel like it's a
yeah i think it's like a cultural thing
i feel like the way like um it's very
caribbean influence so the way that
dance is a lot more sensual like yeah
sensual in brackets because like carbon
people don't think it's sensual yeah but
it kind of like looks that way
it does
it kind of yeah it kind of is but like
you say it's not okay five dollar super
chat from brennan ocean i skipped you
earlier my bad the the men you're
speaking of are dead you're blaming men
who are innocent of these offenses
um and then the last one was another one
from
zentiance i think this is a hundred
dollars oh my gosh like this is dope i'm
not i'm nervous because sometimes i get
excited and it's like a different
currency
so this looks like it so thank you so
much remember all the money i don't even
keep money at this point all the money
is going towards new equipment um
medically speaking i'm in medicine there
is a direct no wonder
your medicine
there is a direct correlation between
bmi and mortality it is unhealthy and
clogs up our health care system look it
up heading back to work just stopping by
to show support keep growing your
channel pearl second camera soon yeah
with these donations there will be there
will be a second channel
pearl stance is like the standard
american white girl
that's true that's true yeah that's true
you're outstanding
i'm uh no i'd say i'm pretty basic
that's like what i built my channel on
is like whitest girl on earth reacts
like i can't i use just once ever i like
to shimmy you know
okay i have one more question and then
we're gonna close out the show
would have you ever approached a guy
and should women approach men
and then the question for you guys well
you're a little different but
but it's gonna be for you is have you
ever been approached and how does
approaching like work like anyways you
understand where i'm going okay
i don't think i don't have any memories
approaching any guys to be fair i'm not
gonna lie
yeah but like generally like when i go
out like i wouldn't like i don't feel
like like i've never like seen a guy
like okay like i have to speak to this
guy like i don't know maybe it's just me
i know a girl that i was going out and
like i don't go to like gay places so
like usually it's not like a thing for
me but like i was out and this girl was
like gonna get free drinks and like she
was just like going up to these like
middle ages like men trying to cop
drinks adam and i that's very much like
that's usually a thing like usually
like guys don't go up to middle-aged
women and ask like try and get drinks
out of them which i think is quite
interesting but yeah like
usually with guys it's like
they're usually way more like
how do i say it like up for it like
there's usually way more like
are they they're more like interested in
approaching girls
is that what you're trying to say yeah
or like approach being approached in
general like they plan to approach like
it's part of like what i'm going to do
and i'm quite like an extroverted person
so i'll talk to anyone no matter what
like whatever reason like if i would be
like oh like it's easy for me to start a
conversation if that turns into whatever
like it's not even like
i think like i'll just start a
conversation in general to be fair when
when we started the podcast you said
you're a hoe or yeah anything like that
so do you meet these men like by
approaching them or is it like apps it's
usually online oh it's online okay yeah
and sometimes if i'm like in the middle
of london there's like i'm like
like
the middle life crisis bay apparently so
it's like come that kind of vibe yeah
okay yeah
but do you do you approach girls
do i approach girls and have you ever
been approached
um
recently no
um
i have to think about it yeah recently
no yeah it has been a pandemic i mean
that that is
i'm not gonna let down funnily enough
yeah sadness um
i've been out my house and been more
sociable after
after the pandemic
than before
like during the pandemic during the
pandemic i was out of my house every
single day
like really so why why less approaching
now
why what less approaching now
less approaching you said recently
you know what i like
you will approach a girl
and for me i'm not just thinking about
that moment i'm thinking about okay
later
it's like
when i really weigh up the options it's
like what are we going to do
yeah i can
really this is how
it typically would go
yeah you're going to talk to your
week also
after the week
you might she might come to your house
you might go to the house you might do
what you do and then that's it and then
it's like
you just wasted your time like depends
what is a waste of time but you don't
you don't find girls that like are
interested in dating you or like hooking
up with you because okay cool so yeah
the first thing is yeah
you
okay me the first thing is i'm looking
at you if i'm attracted then that's the
first thing that sold me i don't look
inside your brain and say oh right right
the first thing yeah is okay cool you're
attractive and then
usually for me usually and this is why
it's recent
you'll be attractive but then what comes
out of your mouth
is not attractive and i can't like for
me it's like
i can't sit here and have a conversation
with you about
kim kardashian's kids
i don't care so like you want like an
emotional connection like that's
important i need to have forget the
emotions i need to have
a intellectual heart like an
intellectual connection because if
that's not there then what like
i can't picture myself even like
yeah
like but um
yeah i can't picture myself being with
someone like that i can't um
but you're the one approaching
and like you can make that
approach but i'm saying once i've
actually spoken to them and like usually
that's what i get
oh yeah usually and that's what i'm
saying of recent it's just like okay
what's the point because i'm gonna go
so basically before recently you just
got through a string of girls that were
just annoying to you
basically but yeah
and so then you're like eff it why do it
at all yeah
have you ever been approached yeah yeah
sometimes um how is that
like what
what works best like when women approach
like what do you think's like oh that's
quite cool like we're just like oh that
was like really like i didn't like that
at all i'm gonna say like there was girl
in in um in college when i was in
college
and she moved to me like like a guy yeah
she moved to be like a guy she was like
what is that right
what do you know what is what do you
mean how did she move to you like a guy
okay like a
a uk guy i mean okay okay okay so she
said to me
i'm going up the stairs of the library
i'm very mad like when i was in college
i was kind of always in the library i'm
going upstairs in the library and she's
coming down the stairs she said excuse
me
i turned around and she was like she was
like oh you're paying still i was like
what
you're you're a what a peng she's like
she was like your ping is in like you
like attractive oh i've never heard that
okay
she was like oh you look peng still i
was like
thank you like i like i didn't know what
to say because in my head i was like
like
did you just say that to me like you're
not supposed to say that's like yeah
yeah that's you and then it's like
that specific moment was just very very
awkward i was like
but that's like the girls experience
like majority of the time like when guys
come to them like did you did you like
that or was it where you said a turn off
i liked it okay
i liked it okay but like
she was also banging yeah exactly
exactly
yeah she was like she was attractive as
well so i was like
so are you but i didn't say that so like
she's she said that and like i'm just
there for a minute i'm just like
thank you and because like when i was
younger i was
i was shy
so i just walked off after that and then
again we saw each other again and then
um
i spoke to her because it was like bro
like there's no way she's gonna say that
to you and then you're not just to walk
past the girl so i spoke to her and then
that was that but like that was
i think the fir and the reason i would
never forget because that was the first
ever time ago
oh yeah that's the first ever time that
happened to me so i was like oh draw but
then the times after
it was fine like the times after when
girls who came up to me that like
they've actually came with conversation
they haven't just said oh yeah you look
nice like they've came with conversation
and i've enjoyed the conversation
usually
um
but for me
to conclude i have i do find it very
very attractive
when females do that very attractive
very attractive for the simple fact that
you've got the confidence to come and do
that
and to me it's like it's like
you're not thinking of what i'm going to
think of you you're not thinking of what
anyone else is going to think of you
because clearly you must be doing it in
a public place
so if you don't care about all these
things to me i'm already thinking yo i'm
trying to
yeah yeah yeah
like i need i want to know
what you're thinking because for you to
come up to me and do that
take some nuts have you dated a girl
that approached you
um no
no i haven't i haven't okay so i guess
not that much
do you think it's like the role of it
like
when like the woman approaches and from
the get-go like the role's just like in
a different place than it would normally
be so it's like difficult i don't know
what's your opinion so like if the girl
approaches and yeah power dynamics are
okay the girl's leading the conversation
the girls kind of would you
would you okay wait did you not date
them because because i have three
theories okay as to why you did one
you're not a relationship guy it doesn't
really matter who the girl is like
you're just not you're more of like a
talking phase guy
second reason
they weren't they were less attractive
third
he nodded a little bit
third reason
i don't know like they just wasn't right
but okay what do you think of those it's
none of those reasons no i don't care it
just it didn't it wasn't it wasn't for
me
right now currently like
i'm never going to say to you i'm not a
relationship person because
i really believe i am but
it takes a lot for me to be like
mm-hmm this is my goal like and to be
presenting her to everyone else is like
certain things that i look for on a girl
is very rare like i think it's very very
rare and it's like
when i do find it like you said it's
like
i don't really find you that attractive
so like
i'm not gonna sit here and lie to you
just because i like the way you think
like that's it's not it's not it's not
gonna happen and but
one there's one female oh actually
there's one
there's one female that
like you said she was leading on the um
conversation she was very very um
dominant
to me i like that like the simple fact
that
with any friend or relationship i have
i'd like my whoever i'm with to be able
to call me out on my [ __ ]
like if i'm with you and i said i don't
like his shoes and he just walked past
and i don't know him
i'd expect you to say listen you don't
know him his situation you don't know
anything about him by your side like i'd
expect you to say that
and she was like that
now the difference with this one
is
she was too much like a guy
does that make sense yeah she's she
masculine no not not too masculine just
to think like she was a female
like she went
to go get pedigree she's a female but
like she
what's the energy maybe like masculine
energy
yeah no no she wasn't butchered the
psychology like how she was acting was
so similar to you that he was like okay
like
the role dynamics
she felt like a girlfriend but it was
like um
how did i even know how to explain it
like she
i knew if i [ __ ] up
she's probably gonna like i didn't know
but like
she'd probably try like [ __ ] me up like
literally she probably just tried to
have a dead on that i was fighting with
me on it because okay so that's that's
masculine
that wouldn't have ended well because i
know like if i believe i'm right
i'm not switching right because if i
genuinely be right bear man i'm very
open to being wrong but if i believe i'm
right then i'm not telling you i'm wrong
and she was the same so i was like
we're going to butt heads
this just isn't going to work
it's not going to work bear in mind i
really wanted it to work do you think
that's like with masculinity do you
think that's just like personality that
like that she was a bit more like you
both kind of have that like hard-headed
thing like like stubbornness thing
one more time
like do you think like it was because of
like oh she's more masculine or do you
think it was actually just because like
personality that she but she thought
like a similar like she's too much like
you too much time
i don't mind the masculinity stuff
oh okay as i said again like i
if you're able to call me out my
[ __ ] which most girls don't do
which even most guys don't do
for me that's a big tick that's a big
ticket i think you can you can call
someone out on their [ __ ] in a
feminine way
it doesn't matter how you call me up it
doesn't matter but it did in that
situation you just said it did
it did in that situation
you just said in that situation
the reason is because when she was
calling you out like it was you're both
too hard-headed and you were too similar
and it would be a fight i was so yeah so
so it did matter the way she was calling
you out in that situation no no it
doesn't matter how okay it doesn't
matter how i'm saying
once we are actually in the situation
we're having that conversation
we're not getting anywhere because yeah
we're just gonna both be stubborn but
how you call me up to me to me how you
call me how it doesn't matter like i
don't care like as long as so screaming
at you
so
come on all right let's just even if
it see actually it depends if i've done
something extreme and you started
screaming at me and i knew i was wrong i
just look at you like i'm not talking
about extreme i'm talking about a normal
argument if there's a new argument then
you can get on my face
yeah there's no way but
even that like
you're still calling me on my [ __ ]
yeah i will say to you you're going to
talk to me
talk to me
don't
shout and scream and get like
i'm not an argument but i i like i'm
just like there's a problem there's a
solution fix it or don't fix it like i
in my opinion life is very simple
we just complicate it so if
you want to argue with me then
the door's over there like i'm not i'm
not doing the argument stuff like
talk but
main thing is calling me on my [ __ ]
is if you can do that
you're high value to me very high value
but not highlighting enough to be
girlfriend
this leads me to another question i want
to ask you guys you guys okay you're
short on time okay okay so another
question i have how long do you think
it's too long for a girl to stay in the
talking phase
because like just like getting to know
someone no no girl like
because this is my opinion generally
when there's a talking phase the girl
wants to commit the guy doesn't
and more often than not that's what i
see
um so how long is too long to stay doing
that
are we talking about like you've met
this person and you know you're sleeping
together that's what i mean you're
hooking up and spending a lot of time
together but you're not official so like
that's what i think of when i think at
times like how long that should last
yeah
some people always say if they're like
hooking up with someone or we're talking
we're like okay
like nothing's defined like what would
you
call it you know so how long do you
think it's too long to stay in that
phase
i mean as long as you want it i feel
like if you're
no no i'm not i'm not saying clearly
clearly clearly every person's clearly
every person is different right but if a
girl wants to have a boy you want to
have a relationship like you should wait
how long are you just wasting your time
like he just doesn't want to do it like
he's never going to do it he's how yeah
the point
that he's like
he doesn't give you any of that
affection that you were getting before
what do you mean
so
you might like talking stages you might
talk to you might message a girl in the
morning
good morning
every month every every every day for a
month
the next month you might not do it
you're like listen i've got this girl
she's
there like i don't need to do this
anymore like she's just there so mm-hmm
when that goes away it's like okay cool
this guy don't really care so if you're
into getting the same attention you got
from him in the beginning right for six
months
you've been talking for six months
sleeping and hooking up you're still
getting the same level of attention
right staying there a couple times a
week
what how long do you think is after six
months do you think he just doesn't want
it
yeah 100 but i don't understand that
like why would the guy continue to like
because he's enable that vagina like
yeah
because i really understand if you're
hooking up you're you're talking like
you're literally doing it like there is
a relationship in a sense without the
definition exactly
same like daily thing
because like like you just said it it's
friends with benefits without saying
it's friends with benefits so like what
would it change if you define it like if
you would say okay now a boyfriend
girlfriend like nothing would change
like you'd still make them the same
amount of times a week probably but yeah
i think it was interesting yeah but i'm
saying like
like all a guy has to do to like be your
boyfriend to say do you want to be my
like that's always that's literally that
so so if he hasn't done it after six
months like he doesn't want he just
doesn't want he like he doesn't see you
as a girl from material
yeah like it's sometimes i feel like
girls don't take l's well like sometimes
you just gotta take that
no like a guy a guy i'll take an l and
move on a girl take an l he's the worst
like
yeah i do think that happens a lot that
a lot of women he was just saying
something else is gonna happen like
surprisingly after seven years yeah he
was just using me well you allowed him
to you like get out
i do think men are enabling because like
why are you still why are you still
turning up because he wants the sex
vagina yeah yeah
this is why people say you know
that's fine but at the same time
at the same time like oh you know what i
know this for a fact as i said
i know this prefecture okay
women
are very very very horny creatures
okay
now
so are we
but
we're just very
upfront more than women i think
hit me up
the reason why we're more upfront is
because of
to say let's be honest like we get to do
what we want
you guys don't
and this isn't a very vague um
example yeah um
so yeah because you guys are like
very very sexual like you guys just
don't
want to say it as much because i know
like i have a female friends that would
just be
[Music]
doing the mad stuff
24 7 and i'm not even talking about with
another guy i'm talking about by
themselves
and
like that's that's just them that's just
how they are and if there was another
guy they would do it but in their for
them
specific females they're like
i don't need a guy because
i've got this okay you know what i'm
saying
but the whole the reason why i'm saying
that
is because you're saying ah that means
men are trash no i didn't say that you
you ain't heard that no you said but you
said like that's why
you're like yeah yeah and then you said
that yeah but i knew where you were
going with it yeah yeah but yeah because
at the same time like don't you think
women should take responsibility for the
situation like like
it's the same you know i was in like a
relationship that was really like toxic
to be honest but it's my own fault i
love you know what i mean so i feel like
as girls like
we don't just like take the l and move
on
like it's like we we
we're victims forever you know do you
think it's like part of the processing
like okay like oh this guy okay didn't
find me attractive they're probably not
like on the same page level yeah to
accept that like okay the men are trash
it's just like the scapegoat we've got
to find something
yeah if you guys relate to this show
who do you guys think moves on
quicker women women like as soon as a
woman said i'm breaking up with you
she's already moved on yeah she already
broke up with you mentally like three
months yeah like trying to start a new
relationship yeah is it not bad no i
feel like women give everything they can
to a relationship because and they're
like exhausted all opportunities so they
know that okay because you'll tell a guy
you'll say okay this isn't going well
this is like this is the problem i have
and you'll tell them again and again
again this is the problem i have
and then like three months later when
you break up with him he's like what
happened
you're like i've been telling you this
for like months
now would you guys get back together
with that guy if he was willing to
change no
if he was willing no well no i did so
yeah
i gotta i gotta
why yes
why yes why why not i wouldn't again now
because i learned my lesson
right
but i don't know i think people kind of
are the way they are i think most and
this is what
most of your childhood friends no matter
how much they like change they're always
kind of the same
and i think people like generally your
core isn't going to change and as women
and i've done this right we kind of want
to like mold a guy into like what we
want him to be instead of like taking
him as he is
and like either take it or leave it type
stuff
i think that's definitely true i think
there's a lot of women that like enjoy
trying to change a man to like oh like i
can fix him i feel like yeah
yeah well we're attracted to like parts
of them but then there's like the other
parts like for him he was just like
kind of well nuts so it was like i
enjoyed him when he wasn't nuts
why not for you what what do you mean
what um you wouldn't go back
because like i feel like if i've said no
like if i ended the relationship then i
know like i've exhausted all
possibilities or options i've asked
everything i've done everything i could
that like to try and make that
relationship work when i'm breaking up
that's the point like okay like there's
no other option there's nothing you can
do now that could make me change my mind
so if that's why i'd say like as a woman
i would move on straight away because
like i know in my head like i've done
everything i can to make this work so
i'm not like okay like 100
i don't want to try this again like i
know that all options have been
exhausted there's nothing else that you
can do to change it we've tried
everything this is the end and then you
break up and then you don't want that
anymore
why not like
you guys are crazy
wait you think it's wise
to
to go back to the guy that you broke up
with because he wouldn't change because
he says he's changed now you think
that's a smart move
i've done it i wouldn't recommend it
because i think people are taught anyone
can say
people change every day
literally every day we all change every
day i think i think that's the exception
not the rule
i think people change but not like by
that much that people can still go to
the gym but people don't change your
character
yeah okay
cool
my thing is people change though
and
with change comes reflection you have to
reflect in order to change
so
you're telling me if this guy fully came
to you let's say he let's say he's a
very um
jumpy guy and he's always like oh my
gosh i want you back to the the last
time he calls you he's like
listen
i want you back
um
i'm not going to force you
i feel very like i'm i know i [ __ ] up
this is where i'm at mentally
i want to try this again
what are you guys saying i'm saying
you're still saying no like why should i
give an opportunity to someone that like
consistently didn't want to make these
changes and then i'm going to invest
more time to try and like help him make
that change when i can just go and find
somebody else that already has that
doesn't need to be changed is already
like i can already accept them how they
are like i don't like with a
relationship you shouldn't be wanting to
change the person you're with or like
want to change them like oh like i want
you to be like this like you can grow
with them but you shouldn't be like oh
yeah like it'd be great if you like you
went to the gym more or something like
that like then you shouldn't be together
well and what are the odds
this is this is why i don't think people
change we're creatures of habit
yeah so you can you can maybe change for
six months a year
and but like what are the odds you're
gonna change the rest of your life and
this is coming from someone like
i i was
i was a big drinker in college and i
quit i quit drinking right now i don't
drink at all but i know the amount of
work that it took to get to the point
where like i can you know be here and
not drink it all and i don't even care
but that took like
oh my god so much i used to love to get
like [ __ ] up
but
but
i know most people aren't going to do
that
yeah
there you go most people are going to do
that so then
doesn't it depend on the guy's values
and how he is as a person because like
let's say
he always let's say he was
he was he was always talking about
change and how he wanted to get better
let's say he was talking about that but
he never actually did it that's just he
was just talking yeah
and then you broke you're broken up it
caused you
a month two months maybe six months
later
tone's different everything's different
isn't that him changing like you said
that's him
he's drinking i had that really similar
thing happen actually that was like
exactly what happened to me and it did
not turn out well
story time can we find out what's going
on no because my no because my
he's watching
no no he's just
he's like fame like he's got too big of
a follower
um
but
yeah that did not that worked out very
poorly and i was like and that's what
and that's what i talked to my dad about
because he was like no people are how
they are at their core you can't change
someone's score they can maybe change
like certain habits and that's the same
thing with me like i changed a habit
like drinking that was a habit but yeah
i'm always gonna be i'm always gonna be
a chit chatter i'm always gonna be a
talker i'm always gonna be high energy
like there's parts of yourself you
really can't change but you can change
habits but
it's a lot of work let me tell you and
some people are willing to put in that
work for the right person yeah but like
there's no promise that that change will
stay
should you if you have to change
yourself so much maybe that's not the
right person yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
100
100
i don't know man
did that happen to you did you did you
come back to a girl
did you were you the guy calling asking
that you changed
i'm a very masculine person but you see
when i have to
i will let all of that go
let order that was outside the window
playing the guitar like
i was
not playing the guitar
wait how how long did you guys date for
uh
two
under half years i think would she ask
you to change would you ask me to change
yeah you know what
she wasn't asking me to change nothing
that's the funny part
um
our communication was terrible so she
probably wanted me to change a bunch of
things but she never said anything so
the reason why we broke up was mainly
because of me
and what'd you do i was asking her to
change a bunch of things uh-huh you were
asking her to change a bunch of stuff
and then she dumped you you basically
yeah well of course and so so then you
were like begging for her back
um
yeah but like
was this recently no no no how you put
it it's not um
it wasn't like that like it wasn't like
that
how do you even explain this
as i said i was [ __ ] up yeah um what
did you do i was being a narcissist
without knowing i was being a narcissist
i'd be so honest with you because like
for instance because i've watched your
um
podcast okay
and with all the girls on it in my head
i was thinking these girls don't even
look because
for me i looked and i was like bro you
were
like this whole men are trash sit like i
completely agreed with it but for myself
because i was like bro this is
bottom level and for me where i want to
be like
it's not it's not where i was i
understand so
it was like
i need to
better myself so
the next
woman that comes along or whatever how
are you being a narcissist i don't
understand oh were you were you lying to
her oh
were you cheating on her
um
topic basically yeah
i'd be like
um
i'll just sit like i can't give you
another exact example because i can't
actually remember like that but
i'll say one thing
knowing that that one thing that i'm
saying either isn't true or
like i'm just saying to piss her off or
just to her in some type of way just so
she can get upset or annoyed
but then i had to actually ask myself
like okay why are you doing it
was it like insulting her or no
consultant it was um like making her
jealous type stuff oh okay things like
like like girlfriend like female friends
okay okay do you think it was just like
immaturity now that you've just grown up
like it's not like you've changed you've
just got
mature like you just recognize like like
okay like i just need to like
grow up you know you know what it
it's like how old was you when this
relationship started
uh
eight nineteen nineteen okay
oh there are you now twenty-two
twenty-two okay
you shouldn't do the maths in it would
you get back with her again like if she
rung you up right now would you like oh
let's
you know
i thought i would i thought i would
because burma as i said i was a guy i
was calling okay yeah bear in mind like
after like a year like so this calling
was
what's happening
um
and then
then i was just like what the [ __ ] are
you doing
i had to have a little pep talk with
myself i was like bro there is so many
females in this world
and bear in mind like i hate when people
say that because like it's like trying
to find a needle in a haystack but
there's so many films in this world and
you're here worrying about one
at the end of the day if you and this is
what i believe for anyone if you want to
be in a relationship you need to be the
person you see yourself being with
in order for you to be in that
relationship so
i think for most guys as well this is
why most guys don't really
talk about their feelings or no it's
like bro let me just get my [ __ ]
together so when's the when my shit's
together i don't need anyone in my air
telling me [ __ ] because i can actually
do what i want so once like getting to
actually
once i've got my [ __ ] together and i'm
not talking finance i'm not talking
those type of things because if in order
for you to even be a good athlete a good
businessman you need to work on yourself
first you need to have certain
discipline you need to
do certain things to even become that
person
ceo athlete whoever it is
in the first place
so
my thinking was i need to be
better for me
so then whoever else comes i'm better
for them
so would your next girlfriend after that
say that you didn't do that stuff if we
asked her
if she so did you have a girlfriend
after that or was that your last
girlfriend that was my last like after
that i was just like [ __ ] this like okay
did you have any like talking stages
like long how could you how can you say
you changed if you've never been in that
situation again
because
because literally because like i
you need to understand the root of what
you're doing okay
i understood the root uh-huh i saw the
weed i pulled it out uh-huh but that's
like saying i'll pass a test without
taking the time
they're just like like like
you can have your driver's license
without i know i can drive
that's a good question that's a good
question but i i i stand by her
what you said i stand by i said i could
do my own open heart surgery like it's
fine
i just trust myself to do it
just ask them about what i said like
i
have been in talking stages
i believe that
i know how to treat a woman
but
then i think i have became way too
judgmental i'm not going to lie to you
very judgmental um when it comes to just
women in general but um
do you think you're judgmental because
like you judge yourself as well do you
think you're like okay you think you're
just as judgmental to women as you are
to yourself like when you're in a
relationship like yeah i would do this
differently or are you just thinking
like oh she should do this differently
one more time like are you as judgmental
to yourself as you are to like the
female partners or the people that
you're seeing i i'm more judgmental to
myself than anybody else that's one
thing i can tell you like
yeah the one like my thing my thing is
it's just self-reflection if you want to
grow as a human being
you have to reflect if you're not
reflecting then
you're not going again what are you
doing like well just like you're doing
this this whole podcast thing you had to
research the youtubers you like you said
if you didn't do that you would be
it would be the blind leader in the
blind
you can't do that
you can't do that so
yeah i i
i um look at myself more than i look at
the other person but i definitely do
look at other person but i think a
little bit too much doing that because
you're judging yourself so much that you
judge women
just a bit more than
average do what you say because you're
judging yourself let me let me tell you
let me tell you that like the way i'm
judging just so you can understand her
like
i don't
as i said the first thing is like mental
attraction yeah i'm sorry
not mental so um intellectual attraction
you know
that's like the first thing
so that's my first thing but then i'm
all thinking about uh can she um
can she cook like that's something basic
and it's not because you're a woman just
can you cook like if you can't
that's just a no from me because it's
like basic like taking care of yourself
or can this person take care of
themselves is kind of like that comes in
that package like would they do their
own laundry those kind of things exactly
and i think that's why i like as i said
the whole masculine woman and the woman
that can um
that sounds so bad like a masculine
woman but not as anyway the dominant the
more dominant woman more dominant woman
um
yeah the the reason why i like the more
dominant one was because it's like
you're not actually just relying on me
you know to rely on yourself okay but
then
hold me up for my [ __ ] when i'm when
i am doing [ __ ] like let's say we're
married and then she paid her half of
the rent and then i didn't pay mine
she's gonna be like what the [ __ ]
we have rent to pay with like yeah pay
your rent
um
those type of things i want those those
her to be able to do those type of
things and be like you know what
you're wrong here do we need to do
okay maybe she'll see this
oh the girl that's the one who's nice
i want him i should be like so maybe
she'll call you
no no no no maybe she said there's a
podcast like look evidence
i've changed
podcasts
just like you said it won't happen again
okay i'm gonna read the final super chat
of the night so um thank you to knight x
i
250 i don't know what currency that is
but i appreciate it
body positivity does not care about
health or science but feel good in a
narcissistic and self-destructive way
like a drug addict
uh thank you julius may's pearl look
beaut looks beautiful as always thank
you i did my hair today i know
um and that's it so before we end the
show i want you guys to if you have any
final thoughts feel free to like say
them and then where they can find you
unless you don't want to be found then
oh thanks for letting me on the show i
think it's really cool it's my first
time being on a live thing like this
before it's really cool um you can find
me on instagram at tiana stanley and
that's pretty much it i also tagged her
in my story today so
um you can find me on instagram at
ah quinlan the i is a
one and then there's a seven at the end
i think i might have said too much so
they might not find me but
i'm gonna do that one
i'm i win yeah like i don't have social
media so like find me oh seven seven one
eight nine
okay guys thanks again this is i think
this is the most
i'm skeptical i've gotten excited a
couple times thinking it was a hundred
dollars and it wasn't but i think this
is my most
like the most money i've ever raised
from a stream so thank you guys so much
for the donations i will be posting what
i buy with these donations probably
going to be more mics and another camera
but we'll